Guten Morgen.
Absolut nicht. Don't Menschen bewahl.
Lockbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer einhund.
Du bist ein ich weiß nicht, ob du ein Tim Ersatz bist, du bist äh Gästin der Sendung heute.
Ja, die hundertsechsundneunzig ist eine Brückentechnologie.
Warum? Einen guten Tipp, meinst du der Tim ist schlechter geworden.
Haben mit breiter Brust. Und der jetzt auch statt.
Aber irgendwie eine, also hättest du irgendwie tiefer tiefere Stimme entwickeln.
Alles äh könnt verraten werden an diesem Zeitpunkt. Genau, wir müssen das ja auch ein bisschen spannend machen und geheime Andeutung, was geht ja auch so ein bisschen so Cliffhänger zu haben so, ne? Dass man so am Ende der Sendung diese okay krass, jetzt weiß ich schon mal das Dat.
Mehr mehr rauchen oder sowas. Und mehr zum Fußball gehen und dir die Seele aus dem Live schrei.
Genau Mythenbildung, so. Also ein Logbuchs Netz für Tick zwei.
Glaub du wirst heute eher mich ersetzen, weil ich werde ich glaub ich muss erstmal zu den ersten drei Themen hab ich kaum was zu sagen.
Neunundzwanzigsten zehnten sein, könnte man sagen.
Ich ich ersetze.
Könnte sie sich vorstellen, dass das so in Berlin.
Ich überlege, wer wen ich ersetze. Vielleicht ersetze ich, ich versuche mich selbst zu erse.
Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg jetzt nicht noch aus Berlin auszieht. Bis dahin und sich irgendwie in der Nähe eines Flughafens neu aufbaut.
Dich ersetzen. Wir haben einen Plan. Wir haben einen Themenplan und wir gucken mal, wie äh wohin wir kommen, mit meinen mit meinen Moderationskünsten. Mal gucken, wie wie gut ich dich in den Griff kriege heute.
Wir wollen unsere Verhandlungsposition mit den Veranstaltern an dieser Stelle nicht schwächen. Wir versuchen.
Thema BKA-Gesetz. Ähm, das war, glaube ich, auch das.
Auszuspielen. Insofern können wir da jetzt noch uns noch nicht festlegen. Ja, das geht natürlich äh hier um einfach nur um harte Kohle.
Was dabei gedacht, die ich nochmal ans Lo.
Mit der wir da in die Verhandlung treten müssen und deswegen wollen wir hier unsere Verhandlungsposition nicht schwächen aber unsere Chefunterhändler haben uns gesagt, so es sieht nach Berlin aus. Wir haben ein Ver.
Vielleicht müssen wir nochmal ganz kurz gucken, dieses Urteil, das war ja.
Berlin hat uns schon das beste Angebot gemacht. Kann man an.
Gedauert. Äh bis das Urteil tatsächlich kam. Mhm.
Die haben ja vor ein paar Jahren den Congress verloren und die wissen auch, dass sie das nicht nochmal wollen. So, das haben wir den mir so gesagt.
Da äh heißt das, weil Sachverständiger und hat es äh Kritik vor allem an diesen Staatstrojaner Einsatz. So, der Punkt,
Sachverständige von Seiten des Chaos-Computerclubs. Ähm dessen Sprecherin du bist.
Schaubare Laufwege.
Ich bin auch Sprecherin des Chaosco-Schutercremes. Ja.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ansonsten fahren auch Shuttle Limousinen vom Atlon.
Als einfaches Mitglied und äh Urgestein. Ja. Ja, also man merkt, dass wir sehr.
Weiß ich ja halt, also das Adlon hat gefragt, ob sie äh ja, also es wird, es wird.
Ähm genau, aber das war dann dann kam dieses Urteil und ich erinnere mich an die Sendung. Du warst so mäßig happy. Mit richtig gutem Urteil.
Aber die müssen vorbereitet werden. Genau. Ja, was denn sonst noch so passiert? Mal wieder eine Reihe an äh an schönen Nachrichten, die ein, die einem Hoffnung machen. Ähm es geht los mit dem Fall von Lorry Lov.
Und ähm jetzt haben wir dieses, also wir sind offenbar dann die das Innenministerium oder was ist dann mit dem Urteil äh in stille Kämmerlein gegangen und hat gesagt, okay, was haben wir denn jetzt hier im Hausaufgaben, an Hausaufgaben.
Nee, das stimmt nicht. Wir haben den glaube ich schon mal vor ein paar Jahren erwähnt, da ging es nämlich um die ja, um die Herausgabe sein der Passwörter, seiner beschlagnahmten Geräte. Das haben wir hier, glaube ich, mal behandelt, ja.
Als erledigt hat.
Also Lorry Love ist ein ähm ein Brite, aber auch ein Finner, doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft hält sich aber in Großbritannien auf,
Und äh wird seit zwanzig dreizehn von den USA beschuldigt, sich an der,
Operations Operation Lars Resort der des losen Hackerkollektivs äh Nonnemis beteiligt zu haben,
diese Operation Last Resort war Lose verbunden mit einer Rache für den Tod von Aaron Swats ähm den wir ja hier auch damals ausführlich behandelt haben,
kurz zusammengefasst, er hatte äh Scientific Journals gecrallt aus einem aus dem MIT, äh wurde dann.
Aber äh ja vielleicht reden wir kurz.
Rechtlich verfolgt und belangt und mit drakonischen Strafen bedroht und äh so,
den Suizid.
Neue Ausrichtung der.
Eines der,
bitteren Opfer, die die Bewegung hinnehmen musste und das eben auch nicht hinnehmen wollte. Und da gab's, da kam es dann eben unter anderem zu diesen Protesthacks ähm.
Kommt ein bisschen drauf an, ob als als Strafe oder als.
Lorry wird beschuldigt, die Federal Reserve, die US-Armee, die Mission Defense Agency und die NASA irgendwie gehackt zu haben.
Wahrscheinlich benennt ist die Person hat ein größeres, größeres wahrgenommenes Freiheitsgefühl äh und wir müssen sie.
Es gab dann die USA haben zwei Expredition Requests quasi also in den USA geht es darum ihn zu.
Die muss selber ihre Wohnung heizen.
Offiziellen Anschul, keine offiziellen Beschuldigungen, trotzdem haben natürlich die Ermittlungsbehörden dann ähm sind bei ihm eingeritten, haben.
Sogar genau, weil diese Fußfesse ja nicht, äh heißt, du darfst nicht aus der Wohnung raus, sondern die der Fußfessel werden ja quasi Bereich.
Seine Geräte beschlagnahmt, da gab es dann ein.
Von acht bis se.
Ein Gerichtsverfahren, wo sie versucht haben, ihn zu zwingen, die Passwörter,
seinen verschlüsselten Geräten, damit sie dort die Beweise ähm.
System so programmiert, dass du dich von da bis dann bei der Arbeit aufzuhalten hast und wenn du von dem vorprogrammi.
Bringen können, dass die Geräte ihm auch gehörten. Also es war irgendwie so, das ist ja immer wie dann in in England äh argumentiert wird, ist ja auch wirklich ein.
Genau, die hält dich nicht wirklich fest, sondern ist eigentlich ein GPS.
Sagt, ich hätte gerne meine Geräte wieder die aus meiner Wohnung geholt hab und haben die gesagt na ja.
Wahrscheinlich auch sagen.
Solange die hier verschlüsselt sind, könnt, können wir ja nicht.
In der der Resozialisierung.
Nachweis bekommen, dass sie auch wirklich dir gehören, deswegen können wir sie dir nicht wiedergeben, ne? Also auf diesem Niveau.
Weil du eben.
Dieser Mann jetzt irgendwie.
Führen kannst und das.
Fertig gemacht, seit seit inzwischen auch drei Jahren.
Du kannst einen Job haben, du kannst.
Zwanzig sechzehn äh kam dann das Urteil, dass er diese Passwörter nicht geben muss.
Theoretisch zumindest so da draußen bewegen, dass.
Parallel gibt es eben dieses Auslieferungsverfahren,
wo es im Juni schon Anhörungen gab bei diesen Anhörungen wurde dann eben hervorgebracht, dass.
Außerdem kannst du äh äh in Winneseile.
Lorry unter dem äh Asperger Syndrom leidet und das ihm quasi in den USA kein faires,
äh Verfahren bevorsteht, dass wenn er dort verurteilt würde, ihm irgendwie bis zu.
Ich habe jetzt die positiven Aspekte genannt. Die negativen sind natürlich, dass das Ding ähm eigentlich eine Vollüberwachung ist, ne? Also das heißt, stat.
Drohen und die USA dafür bekannt sind keine akzeptablen Haftbedingungen für Menschen in seinem Zustand zu haben.
Hast du Tricks jetzt halt ein GPS-Tracker.
Könnte man jetzt mal ausschalten in das Piepen, ne? Ähm.
Da sind wasserdicht.
Und da wurde also alles vorgebracht, um diesen Menschen davor zu schützen, in die USA ausgeliefert zu werden.
Was meinst du, was die Leute noch alles bei Aktivitäten tragen und unter den? Ja, aber du.
Gab es das Urteil? Im ich glaube am sechzehnten September und er wurde jetzt quasi dazu verurteilt.
Ich war gar nicht mit Kaffee, wahrscheinlich ist das mit weniger Sensoren ausgestattet als die freiwilligen Arm.
Er ausgeliefert werden soll in die USA. Er hat vierzehn Tage Zeit, um diese Entscheidung anzufechten.
Machen sie aber trotzdem nicht.
Das wäre.
Freuen sich doch dann, wie viele Schritte sie im Bett gegangen sind.
Anwalt ähm hat auch angekündigt, dass sie das tun werden. Ähm,
Wir sehen ja, was in den USA so los ist mit Leuten, die irgendwie der der Abtrönigkeit äh beschuldigt werden und ich denke, dass es hier schon ein sehr klarer Fall, dass diesen.
Ja, ja. Also das.
Egal was dieser Mensch getan hat, selbst wenn er schuldig ist.
Es ist 'ne, es ist 'ne.
Bei weitem nicht bewiesen ist, dass man sagen kann, dass ihm dort kein faires Ver,
ähm entgegen gegenüber steht, da.
Wahrscheinlich durch diesen Begriff elektronische Fußfessel in ihrer.
USA ja schon seit Jahren jetzt.
Äh heruntergespielt wird.
Kann auch an an kleineren Fällen.
Also wenn man ich glaube wenn du Gefährder bist, dann sind wir nicht im Bereich der des des Strafvollz.
Exempel zu statuieren. Wir berichten ja hier schon regelmäßig über Chelsea Maning. Wir berichten hier regelmäßig über Adsnorden und wir berichten ja auch.
Und dann ist das natürlich eine ziemlich krasse M.
In gewissem Ausmaß regelmäßig über das Urteil von Julian Astange und man kann jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen.
Wir unter.
Diesen Menschen.
Unterziehen dich jetzt einer äh Vollüber.
Von Reife.
Ist das schon 'ne.
Bedachtheitszeugen.
Eingriff. Ähm.
Fahren angeboten worden wäre, sondern es geht eher darum, an diesen Personenschreck.
Allem, äh, weil sie den ja im Zweifelsfall nur formulieren, weil sie, ich glaube, diese Zahl, die da kursiert ist, wir haben fünfhundert Gefährder in Deut.
Und dieses äh dieses Schicksal droht nun leider auch.
In der Lage die unter Kontrolle zu halten.
Lorry Love, wir werden da weiter drüber berichten und ähm ja, hoffen, dass ihm da der Schutz zuteil,
Ja, der auch. Den, der, das wird eben auch als Strafe angedroht. Was? Lorry Love, Kimble, als Strafe?
Neunundneunzig Jahre Haft und Kimbel.
Ja
Also hier werden wir unter Umständen noch sehr kurzfristig sehr ausführliche Solidaritätsaktionen planen müssen, denn diese Auslieferung muss selbstverständlich verhindert werden,
Ja, muss man abwarten, was da jetzt als nächstes äh kommt. Ich schätze mal, wie der Spruch wieder einlegen. Ja, natürlich, also der wird.
Aber okay, das heißt, die Fußfesse wird jetzt weniger im äh wird also weniger gefordert im Bereich der was weiß ich sicherer sicherungsverwahrung, Strafvollzug ähm Resozialisierungsmöglichkeiten, sondern eher im Rahmen der Gefährderüberwachung.
Vorschläge gibt, die haben wir ja hier auch schon ausführlich besprochen. Ja und jetzt,
in die Medien und wird äh auch von der Organisation profitiert,
Ja und die, also dass wie das so ist, ne? Das wird ja dann irgendwann mal zügig die öffentliche Anhörung ist äh am Montag schon am sechsundzwanzigsten September. Ähm im Innenausschuss, da sind dann einige ähm Sachverständige geladen,
die sich zu diese,
Gesetz äußern werden. Ich kann aber ganz kurz schauen, wer das so ist. Es gibt eine Stellungnahme von Doktor Professor Doktor Klaus Ferdinand Gerditz von der Universität Bonn. Es gibt eine Stellungnahme von Doktor Kurt Graulich, dem Richter am Bundesverwaltungsgericht,
Genau, der Mann, der im Keller saß, dann Thorsten Wetzling von der Stiftung neue Verantwortung. Gerhard Schindler vom BND. Das ist ja immer so eine der schönen äh eine dieser schönen Angelegenheiten bei diesen Anhörungen, ähm was sich ja auch immer.
Wenn ich dort zu Gast bin mit mit Interesse beobachte, dass die, die das Gesetz betreffen wird, denn da auch nochmal da sind, um zu sagen, ja, aufhin wäre gut oder nicht. Ähm,
Erik Töpfer, deutsches Institut für Menschenrechte, Professor Doktor Heinrich Amadeus Wolf von der Universität Bayreuth, Rundfunkanstalten, Andrea Vosshoff, die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte,
Und äh der parlamentarische Beirat für nachhaltige Entwicklung. Das ist also eine größere Angelegenheit,
Und was dieses Gesetz ja tun wird, es gibt einen schönen Artikel auf Netzpolitik Orkreute, der nochmal kurz zusammenfasst, abhören darf der BND dann jetzt auch,
in Deutschland, das ist sehr interessant für einen Auslandsgeheimdienst in diesem Zusammenhang müssen wir eben auch die Klage äh,
äh Dezix sehen, über die wir letzte Woche schon berichtet haben, wo es eben genau um die diese Verletzung geht. Ähm die zwanzig Prozent Hürde soll abgeschafft werden, dass so dass der BND auf einzelnen Leitungen inzwischen dann.
Sondern einhundert Prozent abhören darf ähm eine,
sehr große Ausweitung der Begründung der möglichen Begründungen für das Abhören. Das heißt, man hatte klar definierte Abhörziele wie Terrorangriffe oder sowas,
Mit diesem Gesetz sollen diese jetzt aufgeweicht werden, sodass sie also weniger gut greifbar sind und dass man quasi einfach,
die praktischen Hürden einfach sehr stark heruntersetzt durch Gummiparagraphen,
Die Metadaten sollen gespeichert und an die NSA weitergegeben werden dürfen,
Und ähm es soll noch mehr äh Gremien für die Kontrolle geben, statt einer besseren Kontroll.
Dem Zusammenhang ist natürlich eine eine Fu.
Ob liegt die Kontrolle schon drei.
Gefährder.
Jeweils nur einen Ausschnitt sehen.
Höchst inva.
Dieses Gesetz soll eben ein viertes unabhängiges Gremium schaffen,
Dass dann von der Bundesregierung ernannt wird, das heißt auch da, das ist seit wir haben ja einen neuen Kontrolleur, den suchen wir uns selber aus. Auch das ist natürlich keine
Unabhängige, effektive Kontrolle,
wir haben eine Reihe an Nebelkerzen und eine nachträgliche Legalisierung vieler der Praktiken die gerade im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss harsche Kritik finden, um dieses jährige dieser gesamte Skandal dreht und das ist natürlich die
absolut katastrophal, falscheste Konsequenz,
dieser ganzen Angelegenheit, die hier gezogen werden soll. Deswegen.
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie.
Es gibt eine Petition von Katharin.
Die Nähe eines Gefährder.
Mal bei uns zu Gast war zu einem ganz anderen Thema. Ähm.
Oder also wenn der Staat jetzt auf die Idee käme, der Neumann, der es.
Fordere sie auf, die neuen Überwachungsbefugnisse für den Bundesnachrichten.
Und dann klingeln die bei mir an und sagen hi wir haben festgestellt du bist gefährlich hier diese.
Wird am sechsundzwanzigsten neunten eine Protestkundgebung.
Oder Armband äh bitteschön. Als Auszeichnung. Ähm ich weiß nicht, ob ich seit weniger gefährlich machen würde. Ich glaube, da würde ich ziemlich stink.
Platz der Republik eins äh also da auf dieser Wiese, hier wird das beschrieben als mit Blick auf den Schriftzug dem deutschen Volker, aber äh.
Wenn das also als Präventivmaßnahme äh die die jetzt nicht mit im Rahmen einer.
Es von der digitalen Gesellschaft eine Telefonaktion mit einem kostenlosen Anruftool, da geht man auf die ähm auf die Seite, sucht sich die, die abgeordnete Person äh seiner Wahl heraus und klickt auf Anrufen.
Nee, eben nicht, eben nicht, genau nicht. Also ich glaube auch nicht, dass das so richtig, dass das sinnvolle Signal wäre. Äh an einen Gefährder. Ne, der Gefährder ist ja nicht.
Man seine eigene Telefonnummer ein und dann kriegt man einen Rückruf, wenn man den annimmt, wird man automatisch damit verbunden, ja? Also.
Das meine ich, tue ich.
Du sagst, ich möchte diese Person anru,
Genau und äh dann kann man dort mit den Abgeordneten sprechen, was sich ja immer mal wieder empfiehlt. Also das Entscheidende ist.
Irgendwie terrormäßig sich hier zu engag.
Hier darum mehr oder weniger alles worum sich dieser gesamte Skandal dreht, alle Rechtsverstöße, die es hier je.
Also dieses Konzept aufgreif.
Legalisieren und ich.
Genau, also komm irgendwie vorbei, ne? Und sagen Neumann, äh du führst da was im Schilde.
Falsche Konsequenz aus dem Skandal, den wir nun mehr seit drei.
Damit du, damit du gar nicht erst Scheiße baust, kommen wir jetzt hier von kommt kommt der Staat und gibt jetzt dieses dieses Fußband.
Dann gab's noch sehr interessante Neuigkeiten aus dem Bereich des BND, wo man auch gar nicht so weiß, was da schon wieder los war.
Also natürlich, so, ich glaube, äh und selbst wenn äh als ich ja, natürlich würde ich mich wehren und ich glaube halt nicht.
Wie ich ja gerade schon sagte, der BND ist der Auslandsgeheimdienst und wir haben ein hat in Deutschland eigentlich erstmal nichts verloren.
Signal wäre, was den Gefährder weniger gefährlich machen würde. Das ist halt also ich glaube, dass es da schon sinnvoller wäre, die.
Und jetzt stellte sich heraus, er wurde irgendwie thematisiert, dass der BND Kurierdienstleistungen für mehrere Bundesbehörden und Ministerien.
Oder ja oder vor allem denen, die nicht darüber in Kenntnis zu setzen, dass man.
Das sowohl auf deutschem Boden als auch im Ausland.
Glaub nicht, ich glaube selbst aus Sicht der der.
Also du musst dir quasi so vorstellen, du bist jetzt eine Bundesbehörde, möchtest irgen.
Oder Gefährderüberwacher, glaube ich nicht, dass das in ihrem Sinne ist.
Brief von äh A nach B bringen.
Also äh das hat nicht im Sinne des Gefährders ist es sowieso klar. Ähm aber ich äh ich glaube auch nicht.
Sagen wir mal, das ist irgendwie, du brauchst vertrauenswürdige Personen, die das übermitteln und die Geheimnisse darin waren, dann denkst du natürlich als allererstes so die vertrauenswürdigste Instanz, der du deine Geheimdienstgeheime,
Geheimnisse anvertrauen kannst, ist natürlich der BND. Ja, der BND ist natürlich klar, der hat noch nie ein Geheimnis verraten und es steht ja auch Nachrichtendienst dran. Das heißt, er kann ja ruhig mal.
Das ist jetzt äh eine Kritik auf einer noch höher.
Übermitteln. Und jetzt fragt man sich natürlich,
The fuck. Ja, was macht dieser B, was erlaube BND auf deutschem Boden äh sich als Kurierdienstleister zu betätigen? Ähm.
Nee. Also die, die ist ja in die ist ja okay. Jetzt musst du dir nur die Frage stellen. Ähm.
Kunden wurden hier genannt, das auswärtige Amt, das Bundesverteidigungsministerium, das Bundesamt für den Verfassungsschutz, das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechn.
War irgendwie auf deren Bildschirm. So, also wir hatten den auf dem.
Hof und dann wird halt sich darüber wird halt darüber berichtet, dass die Kurierfahrten die der BND vorn.
So, jetzt sagst du äh wie sollen die damit umgehen, ne? Soll also sollen die überhaupt? Sollen die sagen, nee, Ines sind ein Tip.
Teilweise mehrere Tage oder gar Wochen in Anspruch genommen hätten.
Oder sollen die sagen, wir wir halten den im Auge, wir überwachen den wir nutzen unsere Kapazitäten in dem Fall.
Die liegen hinter Hermes, ja.
Strafverfolgung, sondern der.
Weg über Pullach gibt. Und ich meine, denn wenn der Kurierdienstleister der Bundesnachrichtendienst ist, ja? Und du hast Verzögerungen in der in der Zustellung, der ihm anvertrauten Dokumente, dann sollte es schon mal nachfragen. Und das tun jetzt.
LKA, das ist LKA und äh Verfassungsschutz, ne? Die machen sowas. Und jetzt diskutieren die gerade, wenn wir den auf dem Schirm haben, wir haben zu viel auf dem Schirm, dann äh dann geben wir den ein so eine Fußfest.
Und da wird dann wird man sich jetzt fragen, ob die Bundesregierung denn nicht mal erklären könnte, warum die Kurierfahrerfahrten zwischen manchen Behörden teilweise so lange gedauert haben,
Und warum dieser BND hier überhaupt auf deutschem Boden aktiv ist? Ähm das scheint also hier äh,
Also es eigentlich eine äh Verletzung der des Aufgabenbereiches und Konstantin von Notz fragt natürlich auch, was genau passiert denn mit diesen Hochsensiblen,
Informationen, wenn der BND sie in die Hände bekommt. Und es ist natürlich schon sehr äh eine sehr interessante Auffassung von Geheimdienst oder Nachrichtendienst, wenn du denkst, das ist ein Kurier und bei dem werden irgendwie Geheimni.
Eingebauten Taser.
Ist schon also du was? Wat erlaube BND.
So weiter vor dem Fernsehen, dass Leute tatsächlich diesen Vorschlag bringen werden.
Hm. Ich freue mich auf die.
Nee, also die,
Das ich glaube das Problem ist hier eher dass dieses Konzept der.
Du meinst diese LKW-Anhänger, wo quasi die Post während der Fahrt über den äh über den heißen Wasserdampf gehalten aufgemacht und wieder zugemacht.
Teile hat, ne? Also als Strafe, ne? Wenn die mir sagen würden, pass auf, Neumann, hier äh Hacking äh ist in the Netterlands. Du musst jetzt äh zwei Jahre in Bau oder drei Jahre.
Ich meine, dass äh sogar irgendwie in Mobil gab, um halt die Verzögerung bei der Zustellung äh im Elverschaubar im Rahmen zu halten.
Ja, natürlich. Also er ist die alte Debatte. Ist ein Urteil. Ja. Äh und da wär's eine Strafe und da wär's natürlich im Sinne, also da wär's im Sinne des,
Strafvollzugs und der der Idee der Resozialisierung ist es eben 'ne komplett andere Anwendung als wenn.
Wie fahrt ihr denn ja über Pullach? Weißt du? Von Berlin nach Hamburg über Pullach oder sowas, ne?
Nichts nachweisen, aber zieh dir mal bitte hier dieses Ding an.
Ist irgendwie durch eine,
Ich fände das eigentlich ganz interessant. Ich werde hier jetzt auch mal anfragen, was das so kostet. Vielleicht kann ich ja auch mal über die paar Sachen verschenken. Einfach mal eine Nachrichtendienstleistung. Eine Bundesnachrichtendienstleistung.
Jetzt haben wir aber viel über die Fuße geredet. Also äh da ähm Kernbereich.
So, die deutsche Cyberwehr.
Was hast du da bis jetzt gesehen?
Äh zugeschlagen. Ja,
Auch hier mal wieder ganz spannend, ja? Wir haben ja äh erst kürzlich in den letzten Monaten die äh Bestrebungen, dass die deutsche oder nee, es kann nicht,
wir hat Andre.
LKAs gegen das BKA oder ist.
Der LNP. War das eigentlich die LMP einhundert auf dem Camp? Oder war das die LMP einhundertfünfzig?
Ja, ne? Wenn die hundert war mit Ströbele, ne? Ja. Und die zweihundert, können wir noch gar nicht sagen.
Interessanterweise, letzte Sendung als oder vorletzte Sendung, als nämlich der Ulf.
Lustiges Spiel, ne?
Der hat uns erklärt, dieses Trennungsgebot steht nirgendwo verschriftlicht. Das ist eine eine Praxis, ne? Aber es es gibt jetzt nicht irgendwie so äh du könntest jetzt nicht sagen, okay, wir verhandeln jetzt das Trennungsgebot und äh.
Vierzig pro Jahr. Pro Jahr. Äh alle zweieinhalb Jahre. Ungefähr,
Das wird noch, das wird noch sein. Das lassen wir das. Äh also wir.
Wir konzeptionieren das so, aber äh äh wir konzeptionieren den Teil mit den Aufgaben.
Logbuch Netzpolitik zweihundert äh werden noch nicht verraten. Ähm aber da berichtete And.
Ja, aber diese also wenn ich wenn ich keinen. Genau, es gibt keinen, der sagt, die dürfen nicht.
Die Bestrebungen von Ursula von der Leyen, wie wird die Nummer immer genannt, der, der etwas Truppenursel? Ist ein bisschen äh,
Ach so, echt bisschen bisschen bisschen witzig. Der hat die Truppenurse äh hatte ja schon gesagt, wir machen jetzt hier Cyber und zwar nicht nur defensiv, sondern auch offensiv,
und jetzt wird hier erklärt, das ist halt, hat auch zwanzig fünfzehn schon stattgefunden. Und zwar,
Jedes Jahr hier die um die Einheit äh Computer, Netzwerkoperationen, C.
Dieses also das.
Und die haben in Afghanistan einen Mobilfunkbetreiber gehackt, um dort.
Quasi verhindern.
Informationen über den Aufenthaltsort von Personen zu erlangen. Äh die.
Oh ja, der.
Waren im Zusammenhang mit der Entführung einer Entwicklungshelferin zu stehen.
Die Strahlkosten. Ja.
Bis heute war aber der offizielle Stand, dass man dort zwar unter Laborbedingungen Cyberangriffe und Gegenattacken,
ausübt.
Datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Eine Anfangsbefähigung für Attacken aufgebaut habe, aber eben nicht, dass diese Befähigung auch in der freien Wildbahn zum Einsatz kommt. Was hier passiert sein soll, ist zwanzig fünfzehn,
Im Herbst zweitausendfünfzehn, also ungefähr vor einem Jahr ähm wurde diese Einheit vom Krisenstab gebeten, der diesen Geiselfall der Entwicklungshelferin in Afghanistan betreute. Ähm.
Wir haben, glaube ich, dazu einen Vortrag beim Kongress gehabt von der Pube.
Information ähm Informationen über die Entführer zu bekommen. Also die der Krisenstab war in Verhandlungen über die Freilassung der Entwicklungshelferinnen, die entführt worden waren,
die hatten übermittelt Männer einen Kontakt zu den Entführern und die Entführer haben gesagt, na ja, gegen Lösegeld lassen wir diese Person frei. Der Krisenstab wusste aber nicht, ob ähm,
den Entführern zu trauen sei, ob die zum Beispiel,
sich an diese Vereinbarung halten oder nicht und die wollten quasi wissen, bewegen die sich in die Richtung, ja? In die vereinbarte Richtung,
dass eine Übergabe stattfindet. Gleichzeitig hatten sie natürlich, dass.
Durchsetzen heißt in dem Falle eher äh Schlupflöcher, die.
Hand die das notfalls dann gewaltsam, die äh die Geisel befreien sollte,
Da ist man natürlich in einem Risikobereich. Jetzt haben sie gesagt, liebe äh CNO ähm bitte,
ortet die Mobiltelefone der Entführer,
Und sagt uns, ob die sich in Kabul aufhalten, ob die sich im zum vereinbarten Zeitpunkt in Richtung des Übergabeortes bewegen oder nicht,
Die offizielle Geschichte, die jetzt veröffentlicht wird, ist, dass die CNO-Einheit.
Bindung war genau, das heißt die Daten werden zu einem bestimmten Zweck gesammelt und dann dürfen sie auch nur zu dem Zwecke äh verwendet.
Kundenwebsite dieses Mobiltelefonanbieters sich in dieses indessen System eingehackt hat und daraufhin durch das Netz, durch das Mobilfunknetz.
Ja. Ich äh ich äh gestatte der so und so GmbH meine Daten zu Werbezwecken.
Und so dann mehr oder weniger live die Bewegungen der Kidnapper nachverfolgen konnte.
Jetzt habe ich mich ja so ein bisschen mit Mobilfunknetzen auseinandergesetzt und es ist auf jeden Fall also was geht, ist ganz klar, kommen wir auch gleich nochmal zu über ein Mobilfunknetz, kannst du problemlos den Aufenthaltsort einer Person bestimmen,
Wenn du in Schwänezug auf das Netz hast, dass du diesen Zugriff über das Mobilfunknetz erreichst, erlangst. Ähm halte ich für,
Mittelwahrscheinlich. Du würdest eigentlich diesen Zugriff auf anderem Wege versuchen zu erlangen, sei es durch durch das Hacken von Administratoren,
aber das jetzt ausgerechnet eine Sicherheitslücke in dem Mobilfunkwebseite findest, die dir einen direkten Zugriff ermöglicht auf die Location-Daten des Mobilfunknetzes. Das klingt für mich ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich. Also solche Arch.
Einerseits Kritiker sind, die offenbar kein Widerhalf.
Halte ich aber für.
Unternehmen sind.
So noch nicht gesehen, dass das jetzt ausgerechnet der Weg wäre, den eine.
Ähm, habe ich gesagt. Dann ist auch klar, wie.
Cyber, eine erfahrene Cybereinheit.
Es ist ärgerlich, aber dann auch nicht.
Wear ausgerechnet gehen würde. Ja, also das, es gäbe.
Heißt das ernsthaft Videoüberwachungsverbes.
Und das ist das Zusammenschließen von.
Webseite und ähm,
der die einzige, die einzige Notwendigkeit der Verbindung da ist, ist es eigentlich das Billing, also alles, was du über die Webseite ähm,
ändern und manipulieren kannst, sind letztendlich Aspekte des der Abrechnung und nicht der Funktion des Netzes, ja? Da kommt dann vielleicht nochmal sowas wie ich brauche nochmal eine zweite SIM-Karte, dann muss da ein Prozess angestoßen werden, aber du kannst eigentlich sagen, dass,
diese Webseite so gut wie keine Änderung an dem Netz vornimmt. Wobei es könnte ja sein.
Genau. Da kommen wir.
Es ist ja auch tatsächlich äh immer wieder äh so bei den U-Bahn-Vorfällen, die beklagt werden, dass oder äh oder also insgesamt scheinen,
bestimmte bestimmte Täter, also oder die Täter bestimmter Taten ähm,
dieser Aufzeichnungsgeschichte durchaus äh positiv zu bewerten, ne?
Auch damit anzugeben. Guck mal, hier habe ich eine Frau die Treppe runtergetreten.
Spezieller Fall, aber ähm so insgesamt äh scheinen die Leute jetzt nicht unb.
Ja, aber die Information.
Sagen, oh Scheiße Kamera. Schnell weg.
Einfach nichts zu tun und ist eher in dem
in dem in dem Kernnetz angesiedelt, im AJL Aviel A und da hast du irgendwie einfach nicht was großartig, so. Genau, du wirst nicht in du, also ich halte die Geschichte für äußerst unwahrsch.
Finde übrigens wollte ich noch ganz kurz.
Zumindest in der Form, wie sie da erzählt wird, dass der Eintritt eingangs weg.
Nee. Das sollte man ab jetzt einfach immer machen, weil wer wäre gegen eine Verbesserung? Ja. Also sowas wie äh zum Beispiel PK-Gesetz. Warum nicht? BK.
An diesem Punkt ist aber, dass wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass es jetzt ein ein Netzwerk gäbe.
Datenschutz, Grundverordnung, Datenschutz.
So drama.
Verbesserungsgrundverordnung. Videoüberwachung ist Verbesserungsgesetz. Äh. Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Verbesserung der Vorratsseitenspeicherung. Also einfach immer besser.
Eben allein mit der Mobilfunknummer.
Wollen ja auch nach vorne. Wir wollen ja, dass die Dinge besser werden und wer sich gegen die Verbesserung stellt.
Das geht folgendermaßen.
Insofern bin ich dafür, dass wir ab jetzt nur noch Verbesserungsgesetze.
Ich hab's hier schon mal erklärt, aber ich mach's einfach nochmal ganz kurz in sehr übersichtlich,
Ein Mobilfunknetz verweiß wo du bist, weil,
es nicht auf allen Antennen, die im Land verteilt sind, gleichzeitig nach dir suchen kann, wenn du einen Anruf bekommst. Das muss ja irgendwie die Last
verteilen, die Last der verteilten Menschen muss irgendwie auch auf diese Infrastruktur verteilt werden. Deswegen weiß, dass Mobilfunknetz ungefähr zu jedem Zeitpunkt, in welchem Bereich du bist. Diese Bereiche sind ein bisschen aufgetrennt quasi in so einer Art ähm,
nennt man das wie so ein Astdiagramm, ne? Also es ist irgendwie von mir ausgeteilt in Nord und Süd und West und Ost und dann gibt's nochmal eben die Ballungszentren und da muss man sich das wie so ein wie so ein Ast vorstellen,
und ähm so weiß das Mobilfunknetz bis zum gewissen Grad in welcher Region du bist und wenn es dann wirklich eine Interaktion herstellt, sogar sehr genau,
Zelle du bist und bei dieser Zelle, die die strahlt in drei Richtungen, da quasi dann auch noch in welche welche Richtung von diese.
Oder nicht. Der größere Teil der Gesellschaft, grade auf diese Rechte bereit ist zu verzicht.
Empfangs und Sendeleistung du reinkommst, kann das Mobilfunknetz sich sehr genau lokalisieren. Einer der uralten Angriffe, die ich hier auch schon öfter ähm beschrieben habe, ist es,
dass die den Interconnectes Mobilfunknetzes auszunutzen. Also das ähm,
Die Verbindung von allem Mobilfunknetz zum anderen, wo nämlich ein schlecht konfiguriertes Mobilfunknetz darüber Auskunft gibt, in welcher Zelle oder in welchem Bereich sich eine Person äh findet
Das, was man vor vielen Jahren machen konnte, in bei vielen Mobilfunknetzen ist letztendlich über den, über den Interconnect sagen, ey, guck mal, ich würde hier ganz gerne Demothemen eine Mobilfunk äh eine SMS-Nachricht schicken,
Sag mir doch mal ganz kurz, an welchem MSC ich das abliefern muss und dann hat das Mobilfunknetz das über den Interconnect verraten. Dadurch konntest du zum Beispiel schon mal herausfinden, in welcher Region Deutschland sich
die Zielperson befindet. Durch weitere komplexere Tricks, die von Carsten Nohl und Tobias Engel beim,
vorletzten Kongress auch präsentiert wurden.
Die sind gerade.
Mehr herausfinden, aber so ein SS sieben Angriff ist sehr viel.
Na ja, Politik wird ja immer so ein bisschen mit.
Den Aufenthaltsort einer Person herauszufinden.
Den Demokratien.
Hab jetzt mal gerade in den Forschungsdaten die wir in den letzten Jahren zusammengetragen haben geschaut wir haben leider keine Information über die Mobilfunkkonfigura.
Also wenn äh oder.
In Afghanistan, deswegen kann ich da jetzt nicht weiter drüber sprechen, aber wenn jemand.
Du lauerst halt, du wartest auf.
Die Location von Leuten herausfinden möchte, halte ich es für relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass.
Was wir es ist immer dieses dieses dieser Klassiker viel viel bemühtes Bild.
Wo man am Ende auch erfolgreich ist, ausgerechnet die Kundenwebseite sein.
Die Grundrechtsfeinde ihre Pläne.
Das kann aber natürlich trotzdem sein, aber mir kommt.
Ja haben Sie, natürlich, aber also haben andere auch, ne? Also, also andere Pläne von ander.
Am Rande interessant ist natürlich auch, dass die Bundeswehr hier offenbar äh in die kritische Infrast.
In der Schublade und warten auf den richtigen Moment, dass sie äh dass man sie rausholen kann, ne? Weil dann der Wind gerade günstig steht und jetzt können wir das machen. So ist ja.
Eines anderen Staates eingegriffen hat.
Man möchte ja ungerne, dass seine politischen Bemühungen verheilen oder.
Und das zu einem Zeitpunkt, als wir öffentlich noch bei Wahl, bei weitem nicht so weit waren, zu sagen, wir wollen eine.
Ist, dann äh weht halt der Wind derer, die Sachen in der in der Schublade haben.
Betätigung der Bundeswehr haben im Bereich des Cybers.
Ich kann mich da nur anrie anschließen, der sagte, da muss man.
Genau, das ist das ist was, was mir echt auffällt, ne? Also ähm.
Eine vernünftige Debatte drüber haben.
Der Zirkus ist eben, also der der Zirkus ist irgendwie, es passiert etwas und was ähm.
Wir bleiben mal kurz bei den Location-Daten von Mobilfunknetzen. Ähm.
Damit auseinandersetzen, was man mit den gegebenen Mitteln alles verkackt hat.
Es gab nämlich auch jetzt endlich, das war seit länger.
Man könnte sagen ah äh wir brauchen mehr Mit.
Angefragt und ich wei.
Und diese und ähm es ist relativ.
Gab also Bestrebungen des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses da einen eine sachverständige Person.
Keine Ahnung, ne? Ich meine, dass dieser, dass dieser dass diese Straftat oder dieser Anschlag passiert ist.
Von die Auskunft darüber geben kann.
Und wenn du dann relativ schnell irgendwas hinhältst und sagst, ja das ging nicht.
Die Daten über Mobilfunknetze.
Verhindern wegen der mangelnden Videoüberwachung, dann sagen alle, die einen brauchen wir Videoüberwachung, ne? Na ja und das wird natürlich auch kein und was nicht passiert ist, was nicht passiert ist, dass die Leute aufstellen und sagen, ah.
Für gezielte Tötungen mit Drohnen. Das ist ja eine Sache, die jetzt, sage ich mal.
Mehr Daten als ihr heute schon verarbeiten könnt. Offenbar seid ihr noch nicht mal in der Lage, irgendwie ein paar paar Hanseln.
Es ist so, aber man brauchte quasi.
Euch, der war akt.
Ständige Auskunftspersonen, die es einfach noch.
Gar nicht lesen in eurer in euren in euren Di.
Vernünftig zu Protokoll gibt für diesen NSA-Untersuchungsaus.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal bitte wie ihr den ganzen Laden da effizienter gestaltet, damit euch sowas nicht mehr.
Wäre.
Das wäre natürlich unschöne Fragen, die will keiner hören, ne? Also also machen wir ein Video, warum Verbesserungsgesetz? Ja, machen wir Videoüberw.
Da gab es dann jetzt ein äh ein äh Gutachten, was dann in den SANSA unter.
Auch besser, ne? Also Hauptsache ist ja, dass was besser wir.
Wurde und zwar von Professor Hannes Federat der im Fachbereich Informatik der Universität.
Weiß ich nicht. Nein, das ist heute ist heute.
Und als Vizepräsident der Gesellschaft für Informati.
Ob du einen guten Tim machst, müssen muss der Tim selber entscheiden oder die Fragen war.
Und äh in seinem Gutachten.
In der Regel sind unsere unsere Hürden ja sehr äh sehr freundlich. Ich bin mal gespannt, was sie.
Des Untersuchungsausschusses, nämlich welche Daten sind dafür geeignet? Ähm unter den jeweils im Untersuchungszeitraum gegebenen technischen Möglichkeiten Personen in Regionen zu lokalisieren.
Wollen keinen Tim. Ja, das glaube ich ja.
Durchzuführen, also welche Daten sind prinzipiell dafür geeignet? Wie funktionieren die die technischen Methoden? Ähm, welche Genauigkeit äh.
Aber jetzt kommt, da werden wir.
Technischen Methoden,
und ist eine und oder Insi Identifizierung als einziges technisches Datum mittelbar oder unmittelbar ausreichend,
Hintergrund ist.
Es ist so, es ist ein neuer, ne? Also Angela Merkel ist, ist Alter.
Weitergegeben hat an die USA. Und seine Antwort.
Äh hatte nicht die CSU sich dann nach langem Geheule irgendwie gesagt, selbstverständlich.
Ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen, weil ich immer wieder dann das Feedback bekomme, dass die, dass einige der Hörenden hier nicht mehr folgen können, aber wir machen's mal bisschen übersichtlich.
Nee, die hatte schon, das hat schon ge.
Telefonnummer, das ist die MSISDN, dann gibt es die Imsi, das ist die.
Aber immer ohne S geschrieben. Schulz.
Mobile Subscriber Adentity, das ist quasi die im Mobilfunknetz oder den Mobilfunknetzen interne Identität, die man dort hat, dann hat das.
Ich glaub das wird auch von Sonneborn vorhanden werden. Vorangetrieben werden ja Chef nennt.
Auch nochmal eine International Mobile Equipment Identity, die sind alle immer Unique. Dann gibt's noch die Serie Seriennummer ISN und den Mobile Equipment Identifier.
Also ich erinnere mich an so eine äh da wird er dann da drangenommen von wird Sonnebaum drangenommen und dann sagt er irgendwie, danke Chef und äh der sehr nennt den Chef.
Und verschiedene weitere Aspekte, wie jetzt in der MacAdresse, die eher in äh WLAN, äh was eine Rolle spielt.
Ähm ich glaube, also ich glaube weil.
Wenn ich jetzt mit meiner Drohne, ich hab hier auch so 'ne kleine.
Wahrscheinlich mal gehab.
Dieser Drohne sage, ich möchte den Tim töten, dann habe ich ja seine Telefonnummer und dann würde ich.
Ja, aber ganz leicht. Also ich habe, der ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Man hat irgendwann mal so in der, in der Hitze der Debatte, sagt er dann immer, wir reden hier über das europäische.
Über das Mobilfunknetz Anfragen äh in welchem Land Tim sich denn gerade aufhält.
Ja, ich glaube also ich glaube da da rührt das so ein bisschen her und äh mir ist aber also ja äh muss man jetzt.
Tun, da bekomme ich auch heute noch bei den meisten Mobilfunknetzen zumindest die eine Antwor.
Ich verstehe den Mann gut, äh was er sagt.
Diese Person sich im Heimatland befindet oder nicht.
Glaube, da gibt's jetzt äh also.
Wenn ich jetzt Zugriff habe auf das.
Wissen wir auch nicht.
Kann ich sogar genauer herausfinden oder ein schlechter konfiguriertes Mobilfunknetz habe.
Der sagt dann, ach der ich hol.
Genau herausfinden, ob sich Tim zum Beispie.
War mir irgendwie erst gar nicht klar, aber dann habe ich drauf geachte.
Berlin könnte man das dann so runterbrechen.
Mal, dass er.
Fünf Regionen.
Eifer des Gefechts vielleicht irgendwie.
Und dann wüsste ich schon mal, ob ich hier in Ost oder in Westberlin, im Norden oder im Süden suchen muss und dann fliege ich mit mit meiner Drohne über Berlin,
Muss ich jetzt mit meiner Drohne natürlich sehr schnell machen, weil die nur zehn Minuten Nakolaufzeit hat. Aber das kriege ich ja hin, dann fliege ich über Berlin und habe an Bord dieser Drohne einen Imsi-Ketchup. Und dieser Imsi-Ketchu,
ähm out imitiert automatisch die Mobilfunkzellen, die so drum herum.
Also bei uns Erwähnungen gefunden.
Und hat ein stärkeres Signal.
Eher Julia Reder oder.
Wäre er das Mobilfunknetz. Dein Mobilfunknetz kenne ich ja in dem Fall sogar schon. Ähm aber man könnte es natürlich auch auf weitere äh auf auf alle Mobilfunknetze ausweiten. Vielleicht suche ich ja gleichzeitig auch den Holgi. Ähm,
So, also.
Damit war der zum erst.
Kommt drauf an, wenn.
Ich hab's, ich hab's letztens gelesen, als ich als als der dann.
Dann habe ich also imitiere ich die Mobilfunknetze.
Klar war, der wird jetzt Kanzlerkandidat der SPD.
Und was dann passiert ist, dass sich die Mobilfittelefone.
Die erste Bekanntheit hat erlangt als Silvio Berlus.
Bei mir anmelden und im Zuge dieser Anmeldung frage ich sie nach ihrer IMEI und ihrer Insi.
Ja. Also das ist das ist aber auch lange her.
Und in dem Fall, wenn sie dann nicht die den Werten entsprechen, die ich suche, dann.
Ja, ja, da sagte Berlus Koni hat irgendwie sowas sinngemäß ja, bei uns wird gerade ein Film gedreht über.
Und wenn ich dich erwische, Tim, dann sage ich, oh, alles kl.
Da suchen wir noch eine ein KZ in den.
Dann sorge ich dafür, dass wir einen konstanten.
In so ein Wächterpositionen der Nazis. Äh da könnte ich mir sie gut vorstellen, Herr Schulz. Damit ist er bekannt.
Da Sendefluss zwischen uns beiden haben, das kann ich zum Beispiel durch eine Silent SMS oder ein Silent Call machen. Dadurch sorge ich dafür, dass dein Mobiltelefon konstant an meine Zelle sendet,
oder überhaupt konstant ein Funksignal imitiert. Und jetzt.
Habe ich gehört, er sagte irgendwie hätte äh auf eine Fußballerkarriere gehofft.
Kann ja dann durch die Empfangsleistung,
sehen, ob ich mich von dir entferne oder zu dir hinbewege, bis ich dich dann irgendwann nach zwei Kreisen oder so klar lokalisiert habe und weiß, wohin ich meine Wasserbombe,
werfen muss. Und dann treffe ich dich und dann habe ich dich im Prinzip egal wo auf der Welt du dich befunden hast.
Da ist er, das ist ein großer, großer Freund, der europäischen Idee, ne? Steht da, steht da sehr für ein.
Hilfe des Mobilfunknetzes bis auf den.
Als Fußballer nicht verkraftet, hat dann irgendwie ja, so habe ich das irgendwie gehört, dann hat er eben ein bisschen getrunken, dann hat er das sein lassen.
Gewisser ja kann man so machen, ich ich wehre mich ja so ein bisschen gegen diese abgedroschenen Begriffe, das ist ja auch keine Datenk.
Finde ich cool damit umzugehen und eben ja das auch hinter sich.
Peilsender und Ortungswanze und was nicht alles.
Kannst du jetzt natürlich sagen, trockener Alki oder so.
Ein Gerät, was.
Und der auch darüber spricht, denn der äh.
So verhält, ja.
Natürlich.
Ist auf jeden Fall unmöglich mit einem solchen.
Glaub ich auch in der heutigen Zeit so.
Rumzurennen und davon auszugehen, dass das keiner orden.
Glaube, dass wenn Politiker immer mehr machen.
Ähm das ist ein sehr wichtiges Gutach.
Dass sie.
Dieser Zusammenhang, dass das möglich wäre.
Ich sag mal, ob jetzt Strategie äh also wahrscheinlich dann in Zukun.
Sachkundige völlig offensichtlich und es.
Schwächen in ihrer Biobiographie nehmen und sie als als Teile angehen und äh äh.
Gehütet Geheimnisse, dass das auch genauso stattfindet, aber es ist für den Untersuchungsausschuss eben von fundamentaler Bedeutung, dass.
Sag ich mal als in Stärken umdeuten, ne? Also funktioniert jetzt.
Mit mit äh Ruf und Sachverst.
Der der,
trockener Alkehl. Äh finde ich gut. Sehe ich als Zeichen von Willensstärke? Nee. Sehe ich als Zeichen von Willensstärke? Ja. Ja. Lebenserfahrung ähm ist für mich jetzt nichts, wo ich sage, ja.
Für extra legale Tötungen durch ein durch den Staat.
Sondern ich ich persönlich würde jetzt sagen OK.
Der USA in einem Land, in dem sie in dem sie kein Urteil oder sonst was.
Bin ich nicht. Äh nee, das musst du, also musst du erstmal hinkriegen. Okay. Äh musste gehört Mut.
Entscheidende äh Frage für diesen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss und da in Bezug auf diese Frage kommt dieser Sachverständigenauskunft eben eine sehr besondere.
So, es gelingt ihm, es gelingt ihm offenbar oder es gelingt ihm zumindest bei mir das als eine als eine Stärke äh.
Sollen wir mal zu so einer, wo ich fast dachte, wäre eine gute Nachricht? Oder noch ein bisschen schlechte Nachricht.
Fast eine gute Nachricht. Fast eine gute Nachricht, die äh welches Ministerium, was das Bundesministerium für Bildung und Forschung hat eine Open Access Strategie veröffentlicht. Und denkst, wow,
jetzt geht's endlich mal in Richtung Open Access. Wir erinnern uns das Gegenteil von Open Access ist die.
Woher spricht er so viele Sprachen? Weil er kommt aus einem.
Im wissenschaftlichen Publikationswesen und das funktioniert so. Der Steuerzahler bezahlt die Universitäten, um Dinge zu erforschen,
Die Universitäten publizieren das, kriegen kein Geld dafür. Und die Verlage, die das publizieren nehmen, dann.
Also wenn du den Job ernst nimmst, dann spielst du ein paar Sprach.
Universitäten dafür, dass sie ihre eigene Forschung in diesem Magazin lesen dürfen.
Ja, so läuft das genial. Auf so eine Idee musst du erstmal kommen, ne? Und äh die die wie gesagt, die Dienstleistung, die dieser Verlag, äh die die Verlage an der Öffentlichkeit erbringen, Grenz gegen null. D.
Genau und deswegen besprechen wir das ja hier. Also wir haben ein.
Mehrwert, den sie bieten, ist.
Glaube ich sagen, ja, das kann man sagen. Also als diese.
Peer Review äh durchführen lassen. Das machen aber auch in der Regel Leute, die nicht dafür bezahlt werden. Das ist ein ein.
Vorschlag einer digitalen Digital.
Ein einziges einziger.
Da war.
Der diese gesamte Kultur befallen hat und von der von dem zu befreien die Wissenschaft leider sich nicht in der Lage ist zumindest man hat immer mehr Bemühungen.
Hat die initiiert und was ich hörte, was mir also äh mit Hochachtung quasi äh mitgeteilt wurde, ist, dass der vor allem bei jeder einzelnen Sitzung da war. Äh währen.
Oft ist es mit Änderungen, gesellschaftlichen Änderungen. Ich denke, dass am Ende.
Also mir wurde da, mir wurde so gesagt, so weißt du, jemand von dem ähm von dem wie nennt man das vom Format, nicht, Karier, von also jemand der in der Position der äh macht vieles äh.
So, dann habe ich irgendwie gedacht, ach wunderbar, jetzt dann klickst du doch mal drauf. Wenn alle sagen, es gibt jetzt die Open Excess in Deutschland, Strategie des Bundesministeriums für Bildung und Forschung.
Irgendjemanden hat ja genug, ne? Also und wenn der sich persönlich um eine Sach.
Die erstreckt sich über über dreizehn Seiten und dann denkst du, boah, wow, so, dann las.
Monate oder Jahre im äh hinter verschlossener Tür.
Der denn jetzt vor, ne? Welche Anreize wollt ihr schaffen damit sich.
Wenn er sich, wenn er sowas, äh, wenn er da nicht einen Chef unter.
Hab ich dieses Ding gesehen? Ich dachte.
Selber am Tisch si.
Dachte, das wäre ein Scherz. Ich dachte erst, ich hätte jetzt irgendwie falsch geklickt. Es findet sich darin, nicht eine.
Mir so mitgeteilt von jemanden, der eben an diesem Tisch aussaß. Und ähm der.
Eine einzige konkrete Maßnahme.
Also das scheint ja wohl hinterher zu sein. Könnte könnte interess.
Da steht dann irgendwie sowas drin wie Open Access in die BMW Förderung integrieren. Das ist schön, das heißt mit anderen Worten, wenn du von den Förderungen bekommst, werden sie sagen, dann musst du,
Das auch in Ropen Excess publizieren. Das ist zu äh durchaus zu begrüßen,
Gleichzeitig sagen sie, sie äh errichten einen Post Grand Fund.
Seitdem nochmal gemacht.
Wo sie Open Excess Publikationskosten übernehmen. Das ist ganz interessant, das hörst du bei unseren Freunden von Methodisch Incorrect häufiger, dass die Uni quasi draufzahlen muss,
damit ihre Publikation in Open Access erscheint. Und das Bundesministerium für Forschung,
und Wissenschaftler, was auch immer, die hier sich auf die Fahne geschrieben haben, sagen, na wenn das so ist, na dann werfen wir da halt Geld drauf. Statt zu sagen.
Ja aber bei Gabriel wäre es eigentlich egal.
Das ist also also als wenn es heute, also wir sitzen hier zwanzig sechzehn und die Leute machen.
Mein, wenn du wenn du, wenn du wenn du alle vier Jahre Wahl hast, ne, dann willst du, willst du.
Wie sie denn in der Lage sein könnten, etwas einfach mal im Internet kostenlos zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das ist also wir.
Du willst, willst ja keine Opfer haben. Und der Gabriel war doch äh weit davon entfernt.
Ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung, ich erkenne dann nur keine einzige Maßnahme, die jetzt mal geeignet ist, einen zentralen.
Kann ich schwer beurteilen? Ich muss tatsächlich sagen, dass ich den relativ schlecht kenne. Äh.
Das von der deutschen Forschung.
Erst angefangen habe, mir da Wissen über diesen Mensch.
Access Punkt net bietet praktische Hilfestellungen und Information.
Ich war durchaus überra.
Ein Zielgruppenorientierten Einstieg in das Thema Open Access,
Der große Erfolg dieses.
Weil die, weil man's ja zu viel mit Trump auseinandergesetzt haben.
Nie von gehört zeigt, dass es einen breiten.
Wahlkampf strategischen.
Darf auf allen Ebenen gibt.
Unter Wahlkampfstrategischen Gesichtspunkten deswegen.
Ich mein die die Universitäten klagen seit jeher.
Darüber Gedanken machen, ne? Schwäche.
Probleme mit den mit den Verlagen. Ich glaube nicht, dass es da einen zentralen Aufklärungs.
Meinst du Merkel muss weg? Also ich meine.
Na ja, also das einzige, was ich hier sehe.
Also er er die Sozialdemokratie oder die die SPD natürlich.
Ja äh dass die steuerlich geförderten Forschungsergebnisse ähm.
Einer schweren Sinnkrise nicht erst seit gestern.
Eben nicht mehr in kommerziellen und geschlossenen Publikationen veröffentlicht werden sollen, aber das Ministerium betont direkt, die Forscher können natürlich.
Über Jahrzehnte als Kern ihrer Aufgabe und als Kern ihrer Wählerschaft aufgefasst.
Dich frei entscheiden, ob und in.
Immer weniger in Deutschland und wird es vielleicht in Zukunft gar nicht.
Publizieren wollen, mit anderen Worten, wir machen gar nicht.
Die werden sich irgendwie die müssen die Sozialdemokratie oder die.
Also es ist wirklich äh wirklich bedauerlich. Bedauerlich, bedauerlich.
Neu entwickeln, eine neue Idee haben für die jetzt, sage ich mal, für die nächsten Jahrzehnte tragfähig ist, ne?
Wir werden schön ähm darüber aufregen, dass sie nicht.
Ja äh ja genau. Ja, genau, da bist du aber also das äh das wird dauerhaft äh äh das dauerhaft halt nicht tragfähig. Ne, also die die haben ja auch einen anderen Anspruch. Die,
Also vermute ich mal, aber der also worauf ich hinausfinde, ist dieser dieser,
Schulz kommt ihn wieder her und es äh es gibt irgendwie ein eine man merkt, dass die Leute darauf gewartet haben, ne? Also es gab irgendwie offenbar gab es Leute, die darau.
Wir kommen nochmal zur Handy-Location-Daten vor einigen, ich glaube, es ist auch schon wieder zwei, drei Jahre her, da hatte.
Ja, sich in irgendeiner Form mutig und emanzipiert.
Also Telefonica, Deutschland angekündigt, dass sie.
In diese in diesen Bundestag.
Location-Daten ihrer Kunden gerne monetarisieren wollen, damals haben sie äh starke Proteste von Datenschützer.
Personalie wie Sigmar Gabriel nicht machen, weil der die letzten acht Jahre oder was.
Bekommen und haben diese Geschäftsidee zurückgezogen,
Jetzt haben sie bekannt gegeben. Ah äh wir haben uns das anders überlegt. Äh wir haben gelernt, Datenschutz ist ein kritischer Punkt und deswegen äh machen wir das jetzt. Machen sie jetzt trotzdem.
Gute Frage, weil dieser Boost.
Und wollen dann zum Beispiel.
Ne, dass dann irgendwie Schulz kann an Merkel vorbeiziehen, jetzt hast du irgendwelche Umfragen, wo der wo der Frau Merkel ist. Das ist natürlich nicht inhaltlich begründet.
Kette äh irgendwie ein mit einer Handelskette sprechen, um ihr zu helfen, Kundenströme durch das Einkaufszentrum zu identifizieren. Äh es gibt natürlich dann dieses andere Idee ähm.
Keine. Ne, der hat ja nur mehr oder weniger gesagt, hier äh ähm ich habe ein positives Bild, ne? Der, der.
Staus vorherzusagen und so. Also die werden jetzt.
Sehe, ähm, positioniert.
Großen Ströme, Bewegungsströme in ihrem neuen doppelt so großen Netz ähm.
Gegen Ausländerfeinde. Ähm, da ist er, da ist er sehr stark.
Als Information als käufliche Information zur Verfügung stellen. Da weiß man doch äh,
Bei wem man sich wohlfühlt. Datenschutz doch sehr.
Genau, der, der hat noch keine inhaltliche Festigung. Moment, Moment. Geht der von ich bin der Mar.
Ja, das musst du immer machen, wenn du, wenn das äh Google sagt dir, der Facebook sagt dir das ihnen Datensch.
Komme aus Europa und ich habe irgendwie eine äh ich bin positiv. Ich bin und man kann einen Unterschied zwischen mir und Merkel sehen, ja? Den den ja sogar.
Und zweitens, wenn es sind ja auch deine Daten, mit denen du Geld verdienen möchtest, natürlich möchtest du, dass die bei dir bleiben und die Daten geschützt sind, sonst hast du ja kein äh sonst hast ja kein Geschäftsmodell.
Lange Geld mit.
Äh nee, das wäre, das ist ja auch wirklich, also,
Ja, also ich ich behalte mir vor, deine Meinung nach äh beide egal welchen von beiden die nächsten vier Jahre vor uns herzuprügeln. Du willst nicht unbedingt ich würde da eher äh,
versucht ja eher analytisch drauf zu blicken. Ich freue mich auch, wenn der Mann irgendwann Inhalte äh positioniert. Ich nehme eher nur wahr, dass er ihm als so einen Befreiungsschlag der äh der SPD gerade gesehen wird. Ja. Ähm dass dieser Befreiungsschlag äh sich,
sehr deutlich in äh in den in den Umfrageergebnissen.
Wahrnehmung über das Mobilfunkne.
Genau. Und ähm das ist auch eine das äh nehme ich als erfrischend wahr, weil das eben auch bedeutet, dass es hm,
ein Bedarf oder eine Nachfrage an Politik gibt die in irgendeiner Form Hoffnungsbeladen ist und von irgendwie,
positiven Bild ausgeht. Also mit einer äh ich glaube das was der äh ne, der der schreitet voran, sagt so, ich.
Also das die Telefone verraten.
Werte gehen hoch und man kann jetzt da.
Verraten, ihre ihren Standort ja eher dann halt Google Maps oder so, ne? Also das machst du gibt's ja auch nochmal auf App-Basis.
Bemüht ist diese Welle weiter.
Oder Apple, aber hier ist also jemand, der sagt, unabhängig davon, was für eine App auf dem Gerät läuft, ja? Ob's überhaupt ein Smartphone ist. Wir analysieren jetzt halt die Bewegung.
Was er ausstrahlt, vermutlich in ein Programm gießen und dann kann man äh kann man gespannt sein, wie dieses Programm aussieht. Äh dass er bei dieser Digitalcarter ähm.
Und da kommt natürlich das heißt, wenn du die analysierst, das heißt, du sammelst die.
Vor drei Jahren sich schon irgendwie stark gegen Überwachung und für Datenschutz.
Du tatsächlich gemacht hast, was du konntest oder was, was notwendigerweise du erfasst, dass welche Zelle ist, wann, wie.
Mal ganz gut aus, aber ich meine, wir haben auch von Merkel vollmundige Bekenntnisse.
Ein Nutzer tatsächlich durch die Zellen.
Daten hinterher und.
Keine Standardfunktion von Mobilfunknetzen ist. Das musst du dann schon.
Was alles unter Freunden nicht geht und stellt sich dann raus, geht doch, ne?
Explizit einrichten, zu sagen, ich möchte quasi die History haben, wie der sich bewegt hat oder sogar eine äh eine Datenauswertung machen, die mir live zeigt, wie Leute sich bewegen
Du konntest zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt in solche Daten schaust, natürlich konntest du sehen, dass am Samstagmittag die ganzen Zellen bei dem Fußballstadion.
Diese Strahlen. Ich hoffe, dass der Mann in der Lage ist, diese Strahlkraft, die er gerade noch.
Proppevoll sind.
Inhaltlich auszugestalten und zwar in einer For.
Bei ist in alle Richtungen quasi eine Auslastungswelle verliert, ja? Aber das ist etwas anderes als zu sagen wir wi.
Sie irgendwie sitzt auf Seite. Die sitzt, weil selbst wenn er es nicht wird, äh wird er allein durch seine Positionierung äh.
Leute, die aus Kreuzberg, Friedrichshain zum Stadion kommen.
Ja, also selbst wenn der äh im September nicht gewählt wird, kann er jetzt.
Drei fahren und dass die Leute, die aus Charlottenburg kommen, äh übern über die Autobahn mit dem Ring fahren oder so, ne? Also das ist eine andere eine andere.
Zeigen in unserer Gesellschaft.
Analyse die hier stattfindet.
Natürlich. Genau, also als Vizekanzler war ohne Aussicht. Also ich denke, das ist äh auch allen Beteiligten klar gewesen, deswegen haben die das jetzt gemacht, oder?
Andererseits eben auch vielleicht übernehmen und im Zeitraum hinweg äh.
Wurde äh es wurde in den in den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung gefragt, äh wie wir das eigentlich durchhalten bei diesen Nachrichten irgendwie eine äh eine positive äh Stimmung zu halten.
Richtig und damit kann,
machen die jetzt. Also herzlichen Glückwunsch zu einem Mobilfunkanbieter. Der macht genau das, was Tim gerade gesagt hat. Der verfolgt eure Bewegungen über den Tag und führt diese einer künstlichen Intelligenz zu und lässt daraus Geld drucken und die.
Wir müssen uns ja irgendwie einreden, dass das hier noch äh dass es hier noch.
Die Erkenntnisse, die damit gewonnen wurden. Da zahlt man doch gerne seine Rechnung. Aber macht euch keine Sorgen. Demnächst kriegt ihr wahrschein.
Ähm immerhin äh wird es ein interessanterer Wahlkampf. So, das darf man.
Ihr seid dann nur verpflichtet dieses Telefon immer bei euch zu haben und wenn ihr sagt okay oh to dann antwortet euch das Telefon auch und bestellt euch das bei Amazon was ihr schon immer nicht haben wolltet.
Du, es gibt also ich kann vielleicht sagen, warum ich das irgendwie, warum ich das dann doch verhalten optimistisch stimmt. Ähm eigentlich seit dem.
Am Samstag, den vierundzwanzigsten September um dreizehn Uhr siebenunddreißig eröffnet Schwerins erster Hackspace,
Da gibt es eine Menge an Attraktionen für euch. Ihr könnt Tick Tac To gegen einen Industrieroboter spielen, Hackerjapper D.
Mehr oder weniger eigentlich.
Und Schlösser knack.
Feindlichkeit, ne? So, AfD Zuwachs an an Wählerzahlen, das heißt man hat in irgendwelchen Umfragen gesehen,
ne? Oh, da da scheint die Gesellschaft hinzugehen zu im ja einer einer Erzkonservativen,
ausländerfeindlichen Politik. So und wenn nun ein Mensch mit einem Gegenentwurf,
Der Leute hinter sich vereinen.
Zu sehen, wenn wir hier einmal anfangen, Chaos-Treffs bekannt zu machen, dann melden sich natürlich auch noch andere, wie zum Beispiel der Chaostreff Flensburg, in uns.
Weiß.
Space, den wir mit dem Phänomenta EV betreiben, steht moderne Technik zum.
Fürs erste freue ich mich erstmal darüber, dass ein Mensch mit diesen Positionen die in der.
Dort kann man einfach mal vorbeischauen, egal was einen interessiert, dienstags ab neunzehn Uhr gegenüber der Phänomenta im Raum Spac.
Sehr klar in der Öffentlichkeit vertreten hat, überhaupt nicht in der Lage ist, Wählerstimmen zu bekommen. Es hätte ja auch sein können, dass die äh dass äh dass die SPD abschmiert,
Kann, das kann alles noch passieren. Ja klar, aber eben für die heutige äh,
für den heutigen Tag konzertiere ich, dass es mich freut, dass jemand, der sich so.
Loko Netzwertik zweihundert. Haben wir erwähnt gehabt? Das wird ein großes Spiel, ey, das wird ein schöner.
Anstieg an an äh an Wählerstimm.
Meinst du? Ich habe so ein bisschen, ich habe tatsächlich so ein bisschen Angst, ja. Ja, das baue ich so. Ja, Großartigkeiten voraussagt.
Mit Schulz, jetzt ist einfach jetzt bringt die neue Zeit an, jetzt ist vorbei mit der AfD. Jetzt machen wir hier Europa. Äh, ich bin mal gespannt.
Kommen wir mal wieder zu genau. Lange genug jetzt hier, also also wir kriegen jetzt sowieso äh ich nehme das mal.
Also das eigentlich ist, was das wirklich anstrengende wird.
Allen Seiten auf die Nase.
Damit die Veranstaltung so richtig abgeht, brauchen wir.
Äh äh Sympathie und was nicht alles. Ne.
Ich meine, ist alles mögliche. Ich weiß, eine ganze Menge lässt sich mit Geld erreichen, ne. So kann schön Raum mieten, kannst Leute einladen, ne,
Genau, das wird teuer,
So und das schlagen wir natürlich auf die Ticketpreise drauf. Könnt ihr euch überlegen. Wollt ihr gute Nachrichten? Ich find's teuer. Wird teuer.
Weiß ich nicht. Für äh wir werden einfach mal abwarten. Wir kriegen sowieso nicht auf die Fresse. Also auf die Fresse, nee, auf die Fresse gibt es bei uns nicht. Das finde ich.
Nein, wir haben einfach also in den Kommentaren gibt es.
Ah ja, wir haben auch schon es wurden doch es sind schon welche eingegangen, habe ich.
Tendenz zu einem ordentlichen Umgang miteinander,
Ich bin mir, ich bin nein, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass äh wir ähm dass eher Leute, wenn wir Kritik dafür kriegen, dass sie uns Aspekte aufzeichnen, die wir an Martin Schulz nicht besprochen haben. Ja, okay.
Da gibt's eine Menge und da werden, die werden wir in den Kommentaren finden.
Da draußen, der so interessante Stellen.
Genau, wir müssen nämlich jetzt über äh wir müssen mal über die schlimmen Sachen.
Der tausendjährige Podcast. Oder so, werden da schon mal ganz,
Dinge, die Facebooks gut oder albern gelauf,
Highlights oder auch Lowlines. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht zweihundert Folgen Logbuchnetzpolitik, Höhen und Tiefen. Gute Zeiten, schlechte Zeiten. Das wäre sehr schön. So wie es beim.
So und das, was heißt das, genau, also Funkrillie oder äh.
Was ist das für ein Podcast? Hm, Zweitliga-Podcast, eher, ne? Nicht so in unserer Liga hier, dritte.
Der Raum. Richtig Tim, es ist nämlich Lokbuch-Netzpolitik, das hast du richtig erkannt. Deswegen gehen wir jetzt gekonnt über diesen erlebt hat, ist auch Heimspiel, also,
Ach kommst du. Habe ich gar keine Zeit. Kommst du? Wir müssen aufs Stadion, Alter. Ja. Das wäre natürlich sehr schade. Wenn der Tim im Stadion wäre.
Ja, ich würde, ich würde noch ganz kurz einmal, weil ich ja immer äh dreiunddreißig C drei Vorträge hier einstreuen muss. Äh Streu nach Shorn-West.
Deswegen sperrst du dich so dagegen, dass wir das im Olympiastadion mach.
Beim dreiunddreißig C drei und zwar äh mit dem Titel the Global Assestination Grit, also das das globale Netz äh für ähm Ermordung. Für Ermordung, ja,
oder für Attentat oder für Tötungen. Ähm.
Nee, das liegt nicht in Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg. Das wird da hinverlegt.
Die können einen großen Teil davon alleine machen, die können.
Die Busse, die Busse fahren am Friedrichshaken.
Flieg mal dahin, an den GPS Punkt in der Höhe, dann machen.
S-Bahn.
Die Bilder und gleichzeitig haben.
Danke an Conny und Ambro.
Bildanalyse statt, die erkennen quasi Ziele automatisch,
haben ja sogar Insi-Ketchup an Bord, also wir haben 'ne ganze Reihe an an Technik an Bord,
ist aber kein Mensch drin. Und am Ende, die haben also Funkkontakt zu einer Basis und man kennt ja auch diese Bilder, wo diese Drone Operators irgendwie da sitzen, die fliegen nicht eine Drohne, sondern mehrere
können also dann irgendwie rumswitchen, während die eine irgendwie da einfliegt, dann sagt die Drohne, hör mal, ich habe hier was,
wegbomben oder so, dann schaltet der Drone Operator dahin und äh äh macht dann die Killvision oder nicht.
Ähm also Vortrag ist empfohlen jetzt kommt der Punkt, wenn du in den USA sitzt, ne, also im Westen und du hast irgendwie äh Drohnen in Syrien rumfliegen ähm oder.
Wo die so rumfliegen, ne? Ist ja eigentlich, also ist ja,
Bei uns noch nicht, ähm aber in in du hast sie irgendwo am relativ weit äh wegrumfliegen, dann brauchst du da irgendwie einen Funkkontakt hin, denn die Leute, die diese Drohnen operieren, die sitzen auf einer Airforce-Basis,
jetzt sitzen die also so und das heißt da gibt es Funkkontakt hin. Und um diesen Funkkontakt irgendwie sicherzustellen brauchst du,
'ne Verbindung dorthin, ne? Kannst du, wird wahrscheinlich nicht alles über Funk sein, wahrscheinlich nutzen die irgendwelche,
Internetkabel, also ich glaube nicht, dass die Wand übern äh über den Ozean funken, vielleicht doch, weiß ich nicht genau, müsste man sich technisch nochmal mit auseinandersetzen, aber quasi, du brauchst eine Funkstation, offenbar,
in äh Deutschland, Nevada,
Nein. Die eine Rolle spielt, ähm dass dieses Global Assecination Grid funktioniert.
Und die witzige Releasestation natürlich auch am liebsten irgendwo stehen haben, wo sie nicht jeden Tag weggebombt wird und ah, da steht halt Ding erstmal Secher.
Aber das hatte man jahrelang nicht vermuten können, dass in Deutschland eine Rechtslage gibt, ne. Also das hat ja die ganze NSA und äh BND Zusammenarbeit gezeigt, dass man da lange Zeit davon ausgegangen ist, dass es die nicht gibt oder dass es schon keiner merkt, dass es die gibt.
Genau, der im NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss spielte das ja oder sollte es ja auch immer wieder eine Rolle spielen, wurde von der Opposition äh,
immer wieder diese Drohnentötungen versucht zum da reinzuziehen.
Richtig, äh war da. Ähm es gab dann auch, ne? Wir erinnern uns an dieses äh
ja schon irgendwie also als technisch etwas informierterer äh Zuschauer dann ja fast schon ähm
Also das Gutachten äh äh aus den Neunzigern, wo es darum geht, äh kam reicht eine äh Mobiltelefonnummer aus, um einen Menschen,
Auch dazu haben wir ein Vorteil. Genau, der darauf gab es auch den Vortrag, also die Frage ist,
Oder die Frage, die deine NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss beschäftigt hat, war, ähm, gibt geben deutsche äh Geheimdienste und Behörden Mobiltelefonnummern,
Und können Dieken und die Aussage war? Nee, also mit einer Telefonnummer hier, du kannst ja keinen umbringen, kannst du eine anrufen.
Und dann gab es ein äh ein Fachgutachten in dem, sage ich mal, ähm,
Grundsätze der Mobilfunktechnik nochmal kurz erklärt wurden, äh dass es eben sehr wohl äh möglich ist mit äh mittels einer Mobilfunktelefonnummer eine Person äh sehr genau zu lokalisieren,
Und dann eben auch zu erdrohnen, ja?
Die Drohnen haben ja nicht umsonst äh im Seketcher an Bord, also äh was die Drohne am Ende macht, ist, also auf den letzten Metern, um dich zu lokalisieren, äh simuliert sie ein äh Mobilfunknetz äh in das sich dein Telefon einbucht,
und dann hat sie, dann sorgt sie dafür, dass das Telefon dauerhaft ein Funksignal von sich gibt oder in regelmäßigen Abständen fliegt er drumherum bemächtigt sich der Triangulation,
also aus verschiedenen an verschiedenen Runden. Nee, du kannst ja einfach im Kreis fliegen, ne?
Also du ach so, du veränderst. Ja, über die Zeit. Du fliegst im, fliegst im Kreis, guckst du, wie siehst die, wie sich diese Signalstärke,
verändert, die du empfängst, du hast eine Richtantenne, da fließt du zweimal im Kreis, dann weißt du, wo du hinschießen musst, ne? Also diese Mobiltelefone werden genutzt,
Sie sind am Ende das Ziel, wo die Rakete hin hin geschossen wird. Und ähm dass das,
Tatsache ist oder technisch möglich, äh musste tatsächlich nochmal in einem äh Fachgutachten formuliert werden für an den NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss. Und ähm ich weiß, dass der äh.
Sachverständige, äh, Professor Vederert war. Ja, haben das Federer genau aus Hamburg.
Der hat allerdings das natürlich mit seinem Team erarbeitet und den Vortrag gehalten beim Kongress. Hat jemand aber es war ein Teammitglied, der äh wie könntest du denn verlieren? Der Vortrag war auf Englisch, ne?
Gio Location, Meffits in Mobile Networks von Erik.
Okay und jetzt jetzt ist also jetzt ist es endlich das, was eigentlich immer also ne, einmal okay Mobiltelefondaten, andererseits eben diese Rolle, die äh die Luftwaffenbasis Rammstein spielt.
Also es wird jetzt passieren.
Also werden die doch im Zweifelsfall irgendwie sowas sagen wie äh ja aber die Drohnen fliegen ja im äh äh im Himmel.
Also Amerikaner muss man vielleicht nochmal wiederholen. Amerikaner sind sehr, sehr viel wertvollere Menschen,
Und äh aus diesem Grunde gelten für die äh gesonderte äh Regeln äh sowohl äh in im Bereich des Rechts als auch im Bereich der Empörung.
Aber die die kann ja nicht Ziel gewesen sein.
Die stand ungünstig daneben.
Ja gut, die amerikanische Öffentlichkeit hat gerade auch. Zu tun Thema. Ja. Die richtig, richtig. Die hat. Das werden die äh ich weiß nicht, ob die schaffen die eigentlich noch, mit äh hinterher zur Geschwindigkeit äh auf, also was? Oder Legen, die schon hinterher.
Jetzt hat er sich auch noch mit Arnold Schwarzenegger angeleg.
Und dann hat Trump ihn aber als du als du die Sendung, äh, als du die Sendung, die ihr printest oder was übernommen hast, dann sind die Quoten in den Keller gegangen.
Ich habe äh aber es, also Trump hat aber dann irgendwie getwittert, dass die Quoten in den Keller gegangen sind. Deshalb ein schlechter Mensch ist. Ja. Und dann hat äh
Schwarzenegger gesagt, pass auf, dann tauschen wir einfach Jobs, dann können die Leute wenigstens wieder ruhig schlafen, was ich eine ganz gute habe. Ja, in dem Interview ist äh in dem selben Interview. Ist ja bloß ein paar Minuten lang, das wäre nämlich auch gefragt worden, ob er,
auch für Präsidentenland antreten. Das geht ja nicht. Und hat genau, da hat er auch geantwortet.
Das müsste aber, also da könnte ja Trump mal echt eine extragute Ordern machen und die die Rechtslage ändern, damit er auch antreten kann. Und das war so teil, sollte ein Witz sein,
Ja. Ja, lange, aber es ist meine Güte. Okay. Wir wollten eigentlich, wir wollten später über Trump reden. Die die Frage ist, ob wir dazu überhaupt noch kommen äh,
Wir haben, wir haben das Feedback bekommen, da man auf allen Kanälen über Trump hört. Äh so haben wir, sollen wir nicht mehr behandeln.
Aspekte, die wir sollen unsere Kernkompetenzen beziehen.
Weil das die äh APA irgendwann mal in den sechziger Jahren oder sowas entschieden hat,
Also ich wüsste, also ich meine,
Also, dass Donald Trump ähm schon sehr schön sehr sehr eigener Charakter ist, der äh sich offenbar äh der bestimmt, also man erkennt,
psychische Auffälligkeiten an äh auffälligen Verhalten äh und ähm.
Selbstverständlich. Aber da darfst du gar nicht sagen, er Psychologe. War ja auch eine Konjunktivfrage. Ich würde, wenn ich dürfte, wenn die jetzt nicht, wenn ich nicht, also es ist ja totaler Quatsch, ich meine.
Ich glaube diese, es es geht diese äh das gilt nicht nur für Kandidaten, das gilt für alle Personen Personen des,
Nein, die MPA ist äh für
für Psychologen und Psychiater ähm die die maßgebliche Vereinigung. Da ist ich halte das für, also von mir aus, ja? Also äh ich finde das relativ schwach, wenn ähm,
die Verhaltensauffälligkeiten von Donald Trump sind schon sehr äh auffällig.
Allein so eine Reaktion, also wenn du als Präsident, ja, auf den Arnold Schwarzenegger Interview in dieser Form reagierst, ähm dann zeigt er, also dann deutet das darauf hin, dass du eben ähm,
dass du da einen Triggerpunkt hast, ne? Dass du, dass es offenbar ein Thema gibt, was dich in deinem Leben äh sehr stark beschäftigt und ähm über ein Maß hinaus
was einem,
allgemein funktionieren, äh ist da auch der Begriff, der da häufig verwendet wird, äh im Wege steht und ähm wenn du Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten bist, dann äh gibt es,
eine klare klare Konzepte davon, wie du wie du funktionierst.
Natürlich hat ja einer an der Waffel. Also ich find's ganz klar, ich versuche das zu erklären. Ich versuche das nur zu erklären, weil die äh weil sonst heißt es wieder, ja der der sagt einfach, der wäre verrückt und macht dat an nichts fest. Ich kann das an sehr viel festmachen, ne? Ja. Ähm
Also wie dieser Mensch äh auf auf bestimmte äh also,
seine Dinge, die seine eigenen, seine eigene Rolle und seinen Selbstwert angehen, reagiert, ja? Also wenn du
Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten, ja deren Antrittsbesuch bei der CIA maß. Und nix besseres zu tun hast, als darüber zu reden, der du auf dem Cover der Times bist
ja? Oder wenn du als Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten einem mehrtägigen,
eine mehrtägige Auseinandersetzung mit den Medien führst, die du bis in ein,
selber den Begriff Krieg verwendest, weil es Bilder gibt davon, dass deine Fucking in Auguration weniger Besucher hatte als jemand anders. Dann ist das nicht,
im Rahmen des normalen, ja, das ist äh.
Dann würde ich sagen, äh also das ist auch der Grund, warum ich das so ein Schiff, ich meine, es gibt du kannst genug an dem, an dem man inhaltlich kritisieren, ne? Aber es ist äh ich denke, es ist,
An dieser Rolle, die der jetzt innehat, äh darfst du nicht sagen, äh also dann musst du auch äh.
In Betracht ziehen, dass der halt einen an der Waffel hat, dass der Typ nicht ganz sauber tickt,
und das ist glaube ich ein großes Risiko und da können wir uns natürlich hinsetzen und sagen, aber die LPA sagt, wir müssen dieses Risiko ignorieren, weil erst wenn der erst wenn wir den, wenn wir den nach äh nach gängigen Maßnahmen diagnostiziert haben ähm,
können wir ihm auch äh die geistige Auffälligkeit ähm,
Art attestieren, das stimmt natürlich, ne? Ich meine, du willst auch in anderen Bereichen ähm also ich meine, dieser Anspruch ist schon richtig. Mhm. Du willst auch in anderen Bereichen jetzt nicht, dass einer sagt, ähm,
Keine Ahnung, die Konstanze ist blass, die hat bestimmt irgendwie äh äh,
Irgendwas, ne? Das willst du nicht haben. Du willst nicht, du willst, es gibt nicht umsonst, so um das mal kurz zu erklären, warum die EPR das macht. Die will natürlich auch ihren ähm die wollen,
Berufsetos und vor allem diese Wissenschaft bewahren und die haben natürlich Recht, wenn sie sagen, dass,
der Linus Neumann, wenn er in Deutschland sitzt und irgendwie Twitter guckt und ähm Ferndiagnose kann der keine valide Ferndiagnose machen. Und damit,
widerspricht ihr, widerspricht er den strengen Grundsätzen, die wir an diese Wissenschaft. Mhm. Und an diese.
An die Tätigkeit von äh Psychologen stellen. Ja, tue ich.
Grundsätzlich ist es auch äh ähm ist also diese Regel ist sinnvoll
Aber warum kannst du eine Demokratie eigentlich nicht einfach auch in irren Willen? Was kannst du machen? Hast du ja gesehen. Problemlos. Richtig. So, also
Problemlos, ist gar kein Thema so.
ich glaube ja, dass du kannst sogar, du kannst sogar eine Irrin nicht wählen und der wird trotzdem Präsident. Also es ist eine Demokratie, es äh.
Dadurch, dadurch schöne äh dadurch schöne ähm Analysen gehört. Ähm die also sagen so, du willst ja eigentlich auch einen Pressesprecher haben, der äh den Charakter,
und den Willen des Präsidenten auch rüberbringt, ne? Also du würdest dir jetzt nicht,
Du würdest ja keinen anderen, äh du würdest ja keinen anderen Pressesprecher für Trump für voll nehmen. Also eine andere Pressesprecher könnte den auch nicht rüberbringen,
wen soll der sich denn sonst nehmen? Also ähm,
das Spannende ist natürlich, dass äh das Spannende ist, dass ähm äh Donald Trump ja auch nicht wirklich.
Wahrscheinlich sich, also wie jeder, also wenn du Präsident bist
Dann hast du ein ein sehr breites Feld an an Aufgaben und Tätigkeiten und Themen und den kannst du nicht, also ist nicht etwas, als würdest du selber deine Hausaufgaben machen. Du lässt die von Leuten machen, ne? Du hast einen Stab
Äh und das ist ja das, wo wir jetzt auch so ein bisschen äh die Richtung, in die wir gehen,
dass Trump eben Berater hat, die ihm das, was er sich da irgendwie vorstellt oder was er nach außen vertritt vorschlagen und umsetzen und so weiter,
Steve Bennon bei uns schon öfter Thema gewesen. Ähm eben also ein ein,
ein weiß Nationalist oder was, White Supremicist oder äh also,
der Typ, der letztendlich das das Mastermind hinter dem Wahlsieg Trumps, das kann man schon so nennen, äh der das seit der das seit Jahren drauf hingearbeitet hat, ähm ich kann da immer nur nochmal diesen Artikel empfehlen,
operative in Amerika,
fällt mir der Autor gerade nicht. Ja, du hast ihn schon mal verlinkt. Ähm, ich habe den öfter schon verlinkt, da konnte man also quasi genau sehen, dass der, der hat halt Jahre drauf hingearbeitet, ja.
der wird jetzt auch natürlich entsprechend kommt er in die einflussreiche Position.
Und genau während da der Geheimdienstchef und wer noch rausgeflogen.
Ist das so, dass sie die können mitreden, wer im National Security Countdown sitz.
Fachberäter von Militärungeheimdiensten, also Clepper und Militär äh sind rausgeflogen, dafür kommt's die Bennon und Raines Prebis rein. Äh es ist.
Es ist aber auch ein großer Teil seiner Sympathie, oder? Also würden wir äh würden wir all jede Tradition und Konvention,
Gutheißen oder ist es eine Konvention? Das ist eine Konvention gibt, ist die jetzt schützenswert.
Genau, das ist volksnah, das ist äh so also muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, was der in der ersten Woche hingehauen hat, ne, das ist äh beeindruckend. Äh also muss man neidlos anerkennen, ähm ist zwar alles nur Executive Orders äh und ist alles.
Jetzt haben wir zu schon zweimal Massen in Ben genannt. Äh genannt, jetzt müssen wir mal darüber reden. Also.
Genau, denn die Möglichkeiten sind begrenzt. Es gab ja dann noch diese ähm äh District Atterney oder ähm.
Die Range. Es gibt ja keinen äh zu sagen,
Also das ist sozusagen nur eine Position, die man bis ein neuer, bestimmtes einnimmt. Und ähm die hat es sich geweigert. Also der sozusagen der Ersatz bis der Minister da Ministerium wieder übernimmt. Mhm. Ähm die hatte sich geweigert, das so,
die Tat umzusetzen und dafür hat Trump sie dann weniger Stunden später gefeuert. Ja, die wurde, also die wurde äh rausgeworfen und des Verrats äh äh,
bezichtigt. Äh Selliates äh die hatte sich also kritisch über diese Regelung geäußert. Schriftlich. Also Rechtmäßigkeit angezweifelt hat aber dann die vollständige äh Umsetzung äh,
Verweigert äh und das das ist das, was er als als quasi als strategischer Fehler äh äh angelastet wird, nicht nur nicht nur die,
als,
unrechtmäßig oder an Konstitutionschnitt zu beanstandenen Aspekte. Die hätte ja sagen können, okay, pass auf, so und so weit gehe ich nicht, weil ist an Konstitutional
aber dem gesamten dem grundsätzlichen Ding leiste ich Folge und die hat einfach gesagt, haben wir so nicht bestellt, wird's noch nicht gegessen,
Und dann wurde sie des Verrats am Justizministerium äh äh bezichtigt und irgendwie innerhalb kürzester Zeit gefeuert.
Ja das soll grundsätzlich, ne? Das ist alles nur noch Twitter jetzt.
Ja, der hat ja auch noch mehr Follower gerade, oder? Ich weiß. Ja, äh. Du willst auch Forscherbots überleiten oder was?
Natürlich, aber also was was nochmal interessant werden könnte äh ist also sollte er,
diese erste Amtszeit durch durchbekommen, also sollte man ihnen nicht vorher äh unschädlich machen.
Mehr als jeder andere auf sein historisches Erbe achten,
Ne, also das ist ja irgendwie die Präsidenten in der in der ersten Amtszeit. Ja, wirst du den, du wirst den irgendwann mehr kriegen können
ähm der macht sich sehr viel daraus, äh wie über ihn öffentlich berichtet wird. Oh ja. Äh und äh da darüber wird das eigentlich interessant, dass die also noch ähm,
Also noch Versetzt er irgendwie die Welt in Angst und Schrecken, indem er dann irgendwie Fake News schreit und irgendwie irgendwie gesagt CNN soll, äh soll pleite gemacht werden äh.
Ach so, das ist auch noch ein spannender Aspekt, ne? Also ich meine, dieses Fake News-Geschrei ist auf einer also am Ende ist,
glaube ich einerseits setzt, stellt er sich gegen die Presse stärker als jeder andere vor ihm. Ach das stimmt. Andererseits, aber das macht er vor allem, weil er,
weil das ihn persönlich mitnimmt und zwar mehr als jeden anderen,
was in dieser Presse steht, ja? Also der gibt sich ernsthaft die Blöße äh zu strampeln, wenn irgendjemand völlig egal wer, ne, irgendwas äh Negatives über einen Schreit, dann dann wird der sofort unsachlich und schreit rum. Und ähm,
wenn er diesen Kampf gegen die Medien im Sinne von ich will, dass den einfach niemand mehr glaubt.
Den wird er nicht vollständig gewinnen,
wenn er Glück hat, es schaffen, dass ein Großteil der Menschen genug Menschen den Medien nicht mehr glauben, sondern lieber den Präsidenten.
Wenn er Glück hat, wird er das hinkriegen, dann werden, wird es aber immer noch Medien geben, die schlecht ist über ihn schreiben. Und der wird nicht aufhören, sich aus dem was sie schreiben, etwas zu machen,
Äh und ne, also der,
Das könnte im weiteren Verlauf nochmal interessant werden und Einfluss sein. Es gibt ja eine Reaktion. Ich finde ja auch interessant zu beobachten, wie die angegriffene Presse darauf reagiert. Mhm. Das hat man bei der ersten Pressekonferenz sehr gut gesehen
Man hat's gesehen bei dem Streit um äh die die Menge der Menschen sozusagen bei der Angelobung, also man hat ja, man sieht ja, wie die reagieren. Also ich
bemerkenswert, wie die seriösen Medienhäuser.
In den USA mit so einem Faktchecking-Artikel reagieren und einfach versuchen nach prüfbarer Fak
gegen etwa die Aussagen von Trump selber, aber auch gegen die Aussagen von uns beißer zu stellen. Mhm. Ja, die die peinliche Ansage von dieser äh Kellyan E-Segment sie haben sie ja gut zerlegt,
Ja. Also ich denke, die die haben ihr Handwerk ganz gut angewandt, weil Glaube den Trump noch ärgerlicher macht,
Ja. Sozusagen Fakten entgegenzustellen. Auch belegbare Fakten. Auch in der um den Streit um den Waterfroad. Also zu sagen Millionen weiß schon, also die die Debatte. Die haben ja einfach nur Fakten dagegen ständig. Ja, aber den Eindruck, das macht den Fuchstall verzweig
Ja natürlich. Und diesen diesen ähm das würde den aber auch Fuchsteufelswild machen, wendet keine Fakten mehr an.
Genau und das ist, der wird sich immer was daraus machen, weil dann darüber entscheiden,
Also ich meine, der macht sich was daraus, was Arnold Schwarzenegger in irgendein ne, also das wird unter Umständen nochmal äh eine Möglichkeit sein, den sehr stark ähm,
zu beeinflussen. Den Triggern in dem Sinne, jetzt,
Ist das das, was auch irgendwie, ne, also vielleicht auch nicht. Äh vielleicht ist der auch schon so weit weg von der äh von der Realität, dass der äh,
quasi irgendwann einfach nur noch auf den Knopf drückt, ne? Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, äh dass man ihn mit mit äh mit ähm,
Dass man da irgendwann nochmal eine Möglichkeit hat, den vor dem aller, allerschlimmsten zu bewahren.
Na ja, also du musst ja äh du musst dir ja anschauen, wie der ähm also bisher,
in dem was man von ihm öffentlich gesehen hat, wie er Konflikte austrägt,
Der eskaliert Konflikte und zwar offen auf ein äh im diplomatischen Bereich noch nie da gewesen ist Niveau. Ja, sehr peinlich auch. Also es ist peinlich, ist ein Nabel kann man, kannst nichts machen, ist halt halt jetzt Präsident. So und ähm
Gitarre zum Beispiel hin und sagt, ja hier äh diese Universität kriegt halt kein Funding mehr, ja? Also äh,
So, also immer mit der in Anführungszeichen, man nennt das dann, ne, die nukleare Option, ja? Also er er eskaliert die Sachen immer völlig. Und ähm,
dat nutzt sich natürlich irgendwann ab. So und das werden jetzt die die Leute, die mit ihm äh zu tun haben,
in irgendeiner Form lernen.
Der wird an irgendjemanden geraten, der ihn also ihr früher später macht ja damit einen Fehler und dann rennt er damit ins leere. Also und dann ist der richtig am wüten.
Also der der wird ja nicht immer einfach nur allen,
allen drohen können und sagen äh dann dann kündige ich das Abkommen oder so, also irgendwann hat ja auch keine Drohmasse mehr, ne,
Also irgendwann wird halt also irgendwann wird der ich kann das gerade, also ne, diese dieses schon früher Leute gemacht.
Ähm wenn das eine funktionierende Strategie wäre, eine langfristig,
funktionierende Strategie. Und es wird früher oder später drei auch so vorhersagbar ist,
werden Leute Wege finden denen den dieser Strategie mit dieser Strategie umzugehen
also mittelfristig kannst du nichts nix Ungünstigeres haben als eine komplett vorhersagbare Verhandlungsstrategie. Ähm.
Ich kann das jetzt also wenn du mal, wenn du mal darauf blickst, ähm,
Also wenn Trump jetzt ein Narzist wäre, ne? Also bei bei Narzissten hast du ähm,
gibt's 'n relativ klaren Verlauf wie die in sozialen Gefügen funktionieren, ne? Die nämlich langfristig nicht. Also die sind einfach irgendwann isoliert. Die lieber gut,
Ja, aber also es ist erstmal einfach nur eine starke Schwäche, die dieser Mann hat,
Und wenn Menschen diese Schwäche wird nicht,
langfristig eine äh äh vor allem in wenn's um Außenpolitik geht, wird die nicht eine Stärke sein. Der wird dieses Land,
seine politisch in dem, was er macht, vielleicht kann er ein, zwei Jahre auch international in der internationalen Politik durchziehen, dass die Leute, dass da genug Leuten Angst gemacht hat,
bis dann irgendwann also zum Beispiel sowas wie die Europäische Union sagt OK komm wenn der sich gerade mit allen anlegt wenn der sich unbedingt mit China anlegen möchte,
Ist gut, dann machen wir das. Dann gehen wir der der schlägt so viel Porzellan in Trümmer, mit dem andere äh noch eine Menge anfangen können. Das ist ja mal.
Aber wer sich also ich kann das äh ne, wir haben ihn jetzt auch diplomatisch noch nicht viel gesehen.
Lass den mal. Also ich ich da bin ich ganz sicher, das wird äh irgendwie.
wer sich so viele Feine macht, der äh wird den der der baut sich eine ganze Menge Druck auf,
und die Leute werden die Länder, die Außenminister, die werden wissen äh mit welchen Leuten sie solide planen können. Und,
Nein, ist kein Grund, ob die Stelle grundoptimisch. Wenn das langfristig wendet, eine langfristige Strategie wäre, sich so zu verhalten,
Dann würden das,
wären Nationalstaaten sehr viel früher auf die Idee gekommen, dann wären Menschen sehr viel früher auf die Idee gekommen und dann wären Unternehmen sehr viel früher auf die Idee geko.
Hat nichts mit Strategie zu tun, was der macht. Aber das Ding ist, es wird einfach nicht langfristig funktionieren. Auf die eine oder an die andere Weise funktioniert das langfristig nicht,
Sonst würden sich alle Leute so verhalten. Es gibt ja einen Grund, dass wir äh dass wir irgendwann
äh entwickelt haben, dass wir vielleicht zwei Schritte vorausblicken in dem, was wir tun. Äh es hat einen Grund dafür, dass äh unser politisches Personal gelernt hat, damit umzugehen
dass sie öffentlich unter Feuer stehen,
wenn es die validere Strategie wäre, ähm sich so zu verhalten wie der, würden das mehr Menschen machen? Ähm mehr ähm,
Premiers, mehr Minister, mehr äh äh Präsidenten würden das machen. Und andere Leute, die sich so verhalten äh herrschen,
Länder, die äh sehr stark isoliert sind. Hm, Nordkorea.
Das ist aber egal. Mir geht's jetzt nur darum, so also die müssen die USA müssen eine Strategie fahren und die werden eine äh die die entwickeln jetzt irgendwie ähm eine primär ähm,
innenpolitisch motivierte Strategie, ne? Also da werden sie gewählt, da wollen also America First ich hab ja auch in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt der wird,
ähm ökonomische Erfolge verbuchen,
und zwar wird der regelmäßig eben feiern können,
dass jetzt wieder dieses Unternehmen so und so viele Arbeitsplätze im Land behält, weil er getwittert hat und so. Das ist so, das, ja, das ist so,
Du hast mit der machen. Und der wird auch ähm wahrscheinlich ähm am Ende äh äh wenn er vier Jahre äh erreicht, wird er sagen können, er hat Amerika Great Again gemacht. Der wird ähm also möchte ich.
Möglich, in vier Jahren eine Politik zu machen, äh der äh der des Protektionismus und der Isolation, die nach vier Jahren besser aussieht in den relevanten Kennzahlen. Nicht als vorher.
In vier Jahren an den Punkt zu kommen äh der kostet dich etwas. Und diesen Preis zahlst du, würde ich vermuten, nach acht Jahren,
Und in den und den Preis, den du dann zahlst,
Der wird jetzt grade vorbereitet von den, also wenn der, wenn der überhaupt in seinem Amt, in, in seinem Amt bleibt und das durchzieht, was er macht,
Das ist ja eine Sache so, bei dem ist wenigstens klar, was der macht. So, da kann man ehrlich sagen, wenn der sagt, ich baue eine Mauer, dann versucht er eine Mauer zu bauen. Ähm und das heißt, die die sage ich mal sonstigen Staaten können können auf eine andere Weise,
von diesen diese Person als berechenbar ansehen. Und was sich ändert ist nur,
In welchen Bereichen du berechenbar bist. Und genau auf diese berechenbaren Bereiche setzt du natürlich und dann werden andere Länder,
Außenminister, andere Industrien.
Eben auf deine Berechenbaren Bereiche setzen. Und das ist das Problem, was du eben hast äh wenn du Donald Trump bist. Und äh es gibt nicht reine Stärken,
So, vor allem nicht, wenn Sie mit einer psychischen Störung einhergehen, ne? Sonst hätten wir die alle. Ne, also auch äh ähm auch die Entwicklung der Seele,
und der der Strategien, wie wir als Menschen sozialen Umgang miteinander pflegen, äh unterliegt einer Evolution
Und in der gibt es evolutionäre Vorteile und evolutionäre Nachteile. Und es gibt, es ist eben eine Randstrategie, äh sich nazistisch zu verhalten,
die kurzfristige Erfolge äh bringt, langfristig nicht,
Und deswegen hat die Evolution des Gehirns oder der Seele, Evolution of Mind äh zwar nicht zum Aussterben,
dieser seelischen Haltung geführt, aber doch dazu, dass sie ähm.
Nicht mein Stream. Nicht mein Stream ist. So. Wir haben ne, ein Trump ist nicht der einzige Narzist, der da draußen rumrenn,
Politik hast du sehr viele, ja? Also das ist äh äh das ist alles ne, aber es gibt,
Genau, das ist eben der Unterschied zwischen einem einer nazistischen Tendenz und einer nazistischen Persönlichkeitsstörung. Und wenn du eine Persönlichkeitsstörung steht dir im Wege. So und das äh es gibt,
gewisse Vorteile, die du dadurch erkennst, äh gerade mit einer narzisstischen Persönlichkeitsstörung, aber eben auch gewisse Nachteile und die werden früher oder später deine Verhandlungspartner, deine Gegner,
und vor allem natürlich die, die dich, also die im Hintergrund steuern, auszunutzen, wissen, hm,
Das ist äh und das ist.
Also ich sag mal so mal man hat jetzt nach sechzehn Jahren Merkel weiß man nicht wie die abends zu Hause sich an Esstisch verhält wenn sie mit ihrem Mann da sitzt bei Donald Trump kann man sich lebhaft vorstellen. Man hat ein sehr viel besseres Bild von seinem Charakter,
Ja
Na auch war direkt schon immer zu unmittelbar. Es wirkt sich natürlich auch irgendwie echte, ja. Du, du weißt nicht, was im Kanzleramt besprochen wurde, nach diesem ersten Telefonat. Man hört natürlich ein paar Gerüchte, die waren in der Presse auch zu lesen. Aber es gibt diese diese Unmittelbarkeit gibt's natürlich nicht. Und auch nicht diese äh wird mir sehr stark auffällt. Ich habe
ganz viele Bilder. Ja, mein Eindruck ist aus diesen ersten paar Tagen, ähm weiß neunzig permanent fotografiert. Es ist auch immer also sehr live, also du siehst,
unmittelbar auch immer gleich die Bilder, bei dem ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann, der etwa für das Kanzleramt, ja. Obwohl die natürlich also so so willst du diese Unmittelbarkeit,
also ich vielleicht gewöhne ich mich auch noch dran, aber und auch, dass es also es gibt immer kein, es gibt keine,
keine Spanne zwischen Reaktion und Gegenreaktion mehr, also das so schnell. Ich hatte gerade erst die Lesen über Sally, äh also über den Fall der Generalstaatsanwältin sozusagen. Ich hatte gerade erst gelesen, da kommt schon der Twitter. Und ich denke,
Also ich war gestern noch dabei, die Analyse, die ein ordentlicher Journalist geschrieben hatte über äh da ging so ein bisschen um den rechtlichen Krempel. Also was
kann eigentlich so 'ne so 'ne Generalstaatsanwältin und was sind die richtig? Und da kommt schon der Tweet rein, schießt feiert. Na ja, das hat natürlich mal hinterher. Das ist natürlich auch ein äh also das ist natürlich ein.
Da sieht man die Stärke dieser dieser Art. Ähm denn was erinnert wo,
Wenn es da ein strategisches Ziel gibt, dann ist das natürlich, dass die Leute, die sich eben widersetzen wollen, wissen,
Das ist nicht so was wie wir verhandeln nochmal gibt. Ja. Das ist nicht sowas wie äh äh Heiko Maas, Harald Range
dreimal hin und her und jetzt äh alles klar jetzt jetzt eskaliere ich jetzt aber drei Monate später wirklich mal und dann ja dann kriegst du auch deine Quittung,
zwischendurch haben wir stundenlang telefoniert und sind in uns gegangen und dann haben wir den Konflikt ausgetragen nach draußen. Ähm da passiert so viel. Bei Trump ist klar, es gibt hier nicht irgendwie wir reden nicht nochmal,
Damit prügelt er bei seine Leute natürlich auch auf Linie.
Das, das ist die Stärke, ne? Also der hat eine Stärke da und der hat eine Schwäche. Die Schwäche werden andere nutzen, die werden jetzt nicht irgendwelche Generalstaatsanwältin nutzen. Die werden halt so wird sowas wie ähm,
Also China wird sich, die lachen sich doch gerade. Ich glaube auch, dass die sich im Clement totlach,
Also ich meine, also genau. Die Dick ist äh siehst du einen Mehrwert darin,
ähm diese Unmittelbarkeit nicht zu haben. Also siehst du einen Mehrwert darin, dass mit Regierung oder tatsächlich Regierungshandeln nicht vor den Augen, also und in Echtzeit vor den Augen aller stattfindet. Enorm. Da sehe ich eine enormen Vorteil drin,
Na ja wird also weil du einfach bedachter handeln kannst. Es ist doch ein totaler Nachteil, wenn du die ganze Zeit Impuls getrieben bis,
Wir haben uns wir haben als Menschen einen riesigen Neo-Kortex, damit wir unsere Impulse irgendwie im Gr,
Ja, gut, wir wollen das schon Männer und Frauen hier rausstellen, ne? Also ja, du hast einen größeren als ich und ich kann nur eine Sache auf einmal und du kannst zwei, äh ich bin unterlegen, klar, aber ne, also.
Impulsgesteuert zu sein ist eben einfach von Nachteil. Ähm wenn du,
nicht äh also ne, von ist von Nachteil. Ich kann das jetzt noch nicht festmachen und im Moment sieht's danach aus, als als als,
versetzt äh Trump die die Welt in Angst und Schrecken und man ist schockiert,
und man kann nur hoffen, dass der nicht irgendwann mal echt mal einen Impuls kriegt, der wirklich den Porzellanschrank umwirft.
Da kann, also das, das ist das Gefährliche, ne.
Selbstverständlich hat er die, aber der wird äh also sowas wie ähm.
Also die die Gestaltung der Zukunft der Welt erfordert halt ein paar diplomatische,
informierte Auseinandersetzung und insbesondere wenn du dich also da gibt's 'n sehr spannenden Artikel jetzt. Ich glaube das war How to Bill nee der war das nicht. Der war auch interessant. Also es gab so einen Artikel darüber, den hat er uns ähm,
würde mir auf Twitter empfohlen, äh wo es darum geht, dass Trump nämlich eigentlich auch einer,
von denen in Anführungszeichen ist, die äh der die in der Vergangenheit verhaftet sind. Die eine, die im Prinzip die Welt
zurückbringen wollen, die die Leute in der Vergangenheit lieben. Also die Make-America Greticin hast ja schon im Slogan und vor allem der ähm,
sich dem dem Ende des Öls,
nicht äh zuwendet, ja? Also äh der im Prinzip sagt, okay ähm,
wir äh ne, also diese ganze kleine Zeit ist falsch und äh das ist irgendwie ein Plot der Chinesen und so herrlich. Das äh
Das heißt der, der ist nicht in der Lage oder der der scheint nicht in der Lage zu sein, dieses Land äh auf die Herausforderungen der Zukunft adäquat,
vorzubereiten.
Genau, jetzt sind aber allerdings eben keine äh äh zu Klima und Energieforscher, sondern eh.
Also ich esse Wissenschaft ist natürlich auch so, dass mit Trumps Haltung wirst du nicht Wissenschaftler, du wirst ähm.
Das wird der Wissenschaft finde ich interessant. Also ich ich hätte mir zum wenn Merkel twittern würde, hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass äh nachdem er sagt, äh er zieht Jucy Böckle das Geld. Hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass das äh dass Merkel sagt
Alles klar, nehmen wir.
Kein Problem, deine Klimawissenschaftler kommen, äh mach mal eben Executive oder? Wir nehmen wirft die raus. Die nehmen wir auch noch. Wir nehmen alle, wir nehmen alles, was du nicht haben willst,
Alles was ich mit der Welt von übermorgen auseinandersetzt, was du für eine chinesische äh Verschwörung hältst. Komm, schmeiß sie raus. Nehmen wir,
Also das wäre das ist die Chance, ja? Das ist die Chance, auf die man äh äh auf die man jetzt äh setzen könnte. Schmeißt halt ein paar,
paar echt kluge Leute, Positionen raus. Nee. Und äh jetzt habe ich jetzt hatte ich gerade den Artikel und dann kam die,
Also das, was der macht, hat Schwächen. Wenn wenn es eine valide, langfristige Strategie wäre, ein Land so zu regieren, dann würden alle Länder so regiert werden,
Das ist der kleine Funk und Hoffnung, den ich irgendwie noch trage. Na ja. Und wenn wir Glück haben, wenn wir Glück haben, können wir ähm äh davon noch irgendwie,
können wir davon noch irgendwie diese Früchte noch ernten, wenn wir Pech haben eben nicht, weil er vorher den gesamten Obstgarten sprengen.
Der Artikel, den ich in dem Zusammenhang empfehle ist Alex Steffen, Trump Putin and the Pipelines to Nowhere,
Okay, wer hattet mit Putin zu tun,
nee weil also kurz ich mein das hat mit Putin deshalb zu tun weil Ustern auch nichts anderes hat als Öl,
Und äh die sind im Prinzip, also der die These dieses Artikels ist ähm,
dass quasi Öl heute schon eine Bubble ist,
Also, ne, aber heißt äh die die gesamte Pfronölabhängige Industrie wird überbewertet und äh Babels haben ja so diese Eigenart, dass sie irgendwann platzen. Das heißt, es gibt gerade noch zu viel ähm,
Investition in Öl, zu viel Hoffnung in Öl und wenn das platzt, dann rauscht dieser gesamte Rausch das richtig,
ne? So ähnlich wie halt die Houseing Bubble, die wir vor zehn Jahren in USA gesehen haben. Ähm,
Und die These ist, dass Trump grade natürlich genau diese Bubble befeuert.
Sich erste Finanzinstitution, ich glaube über die Deutsche Bank hast du ja letztens auch so eine so eine Berichterstattung sagen äh mit dem Öl,
also wir sehen mittelfristig das Wachstum woanders. Und wenn das genug Leute sagen,
dann platzt dieses Ding. Äh das ist so ein bisschen die die Argumentation, die er bringt. Und deswegen also und genau damit erklärt er auch, dass das Trump halt sagt, diese ganze kleine Zeit und so, dann verbieten wir ganz einfach. Mhm. Ähm,
beziehungsweise verbieten wir nicht, aber äh wenn die nächste Mal was veröffentlichen wollen, dann unterliegt das einer.
Einer politischen Kontrolle durch meine Experten,
Aber dieser äh wir sind hier eben nicht äh äh Lockbuchenergiepolitik und deswegen kann ich da auch nur sind überhaupt nicht über diesen Artikel äh berichten. Ja, da werden wir auch äh werden jetzt viele Leute
noch viel korrigieren und ergänzen nach dem was wir gehen, aber ich.
Wir müssen noch über ein Thema müssen wir sprechen. So jung kommen ja nicht mehr wieder zusammen. Und vor allem wollte ich dich fragen, Konstanze, ob du nicht, ähm, ob du nicht Lust hättest,
Ähm für den Verfassungsschutz ein bisschen den CC auszuspielen.
Also es gab, es gab eine äh was was passiert ist in der letzten Woche, ist ein ein äh eine holländische Person ähm hat äh veröffentlicht, dass sie, dass es eine Anwerbeversuch gab, der die,
schreibt also, dass er äh.
Betreibt Exit Notes glaube ich, denn da und äh kam irgendwie aus der Gym und wurde also aus dem, aus der Sport, also Fitnessstudio, sagt man in Deutschland
und wurde dann angesprochen von Mann und einer Frau, die sagten, ja Mensch, hör mal, hast du nicht mal Zeit? Komm mal, trink mal einen Kaffee und so. Hör mal, du interessierst dich doch hier für Hacking und und so, haste nicht Lust ähm,
mal so zu den Konferenzen und so zu fahren und bisschen umzutun und es nachher so zu erzählen. Kannst auch mal irgendwie,
Deine Kosten, kostet ein kleines Geld für und hier so diese CC zum Beispiel, könntest ja mal hinfahren und mit denen dich mal ein bisschen auseinandersetzen. Genau, also mit anderen Worten der niederländische Geheimdienst interessiert sich äh für die Chaos Computerkrieg.
Dass ich, ich denke, dass es vielleicht was an der Stelle nochmal ganz kurz sein, das ist das einzige, was du machen kannst,
Also ich persönlich denke, dass es die, dass die die Musterlösung in einer solchen Situation ist,
sofort ein Gedächtnisprotokoll anfertigen mit zumindest mit deinem relevanten Bezugspersonenkreis darüber zu sprechen. Darüber sehen wir uns glaube ich einig.
Wir reden ja erstmal nur über diese Situation. Ja, also ich meine, da darf noch tausend andere Situationen geben. Da werdet ihr. Also wir haben auch äh wir haben auch an der ähm in der Datenschleuder sechsundneunzig eine,
'ne komplexere Situation aufgearbeitet. Ja. Aber auch da hat die betroffene Person am Ende nichts anderes gemacht als,
Kontakte abgebrochen und die Geschichte äh öffentlich gemacht.
Na gut, aber Moment, vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen zurückzugehen. Das, worüber wir gerade reden, ist, macht man nicht öffentlich und macht man in der Form öffentlich,
einig sind ist, dass man nicht drauf eingeht und dass man zumindest sein Umfeld warnt. Das ist ja das Wichtigste. Also da oder haben wir da auch.
Dass man, ach, selbstverständlich, also ich ich mein äh also ich würde sagen, das, was die Person da jetzt gemacht hat, ist äh die Musterlösung der Situation
Ne? Also das ist die eins plus. Du hast äh nein gesagt. Äh du hast dich für die als äh du hast dich für für die nachhaltig verbrannt. Du hast eine weltweite äh Warnung
ausgesprochen, du hast die deutschen CC-Leute gewarnt.
Und das ist das, was du als Anlegen bezeichnest. Also du hast dich mit den Geheimdiensten,
angelegt, du hast den, du hast nicht nur gezeigt, mit mir nicht, sondern du hast auch gesagt, patsch,
Also es ist, der hat nicht gesagt, äh freundlich, nein, danke, auf Wiederhören, sondern der hat äh denen eine Ohrfeige gegeben und hat den und zwar eine, die sich gewaschen hat und hat das hatten äh hattet öffentlich so so laut platzen lassen, wie es nur ging,
Okay, hier denn lass uns, also das sind wir uns eingestellt, ist die eins bis die eins plus, die hätte nix besser, nix noch besser machen können, als er es gemacht hat.
Genau und jetzt haben wir, es gibt quasi äh es gibt äh Abweichungen von der Situation und das ist erstens, dass äh die Situation, in denen es nicht so klar ist, in denen du äh,
vielleicht in die dir komisch vorkommen. Ich meine, wenn einem eine Situation komisch vorkommt, dann äh wird man vorsichtig und sagt nichts mehr,
Also jetzt gibt's noch die andere Situation, die wo du wo du wo die nicht ganz so dumm sind.
Genau, der Aber der hat nicht versucht anzuwärmen. Der war ja angeworben, der war ja oder der war ja hat der versucht, Leute anzuwählen.
Aber war das wirklich ein Anwerbungsversuch, was der da gemacht hat? Ich meine, die haben sich auf einmal mehr oder weniger äh in einer mehrjährigen Liebesbeziehung mit einem Spitze wiedergefunden. Das war ja kein Anwärmungsversuch,
Also das ist ja nochmal was anderes, oder? Ist ja eine.
Hat er, okay, das war mir in der, in dem Ausmaß nicht klasse.
Ja, aber warum ist es denn rausgekommen, weil irgendwann Leute den Mut hatten, das äh äh auszusprechen? Sich dem entgegenzutreten? Äh.
Also ich denke also halten wir fest. Das ist der richtige der Mann hat die Musterlösung gezeigt. Genau. Das war die Musterlösung
von der Musterlösung kann von mir aus in in Einzelfällen abgewichen werden, aber die Musterlösungen oder die Lösung
beinhaltet immer sich darauf nicht einzulassen, egal welche Druckmittel die haben. Man machtet ja nur noch schlimmer,
Also ist ja der sagt einem ja jeder, wenn wenn jemand versucht dich zu erpressen, aus der Nummer kommst du nicht mehr raus, so. Äh vor allem, wenn es eben, wenn er, wenn man dich mit,
Dingen erpresst, die eben nicht weggehen. Ja. Ja. Ähm also ich glaube,
man muss da auf der Hut sein, es schadet nicht ein sehr gesundes, vielleicht auch,
Also einfach ein gesundes Misstrauen zu haben, ne? Es hilft auch nicht einfach bei jedem, der reinkommt, sofort zu schreien, ist eine Spitze, der darf hier nicht rein. Das ist genauso unsinnig. Aber es gilt eben ähm ein.
Gesundes äh Misstrauen zu haben, vor allem, wenn man sich auf einmal Leuten gegenüber äh sieht,
Ich denke, so verraten sie sich ja, die eine Kenntnis über jemand über einen haben,
die sie aus der Situation, aus der sie kommen, eigentlich nicht haben sollen. Also, in der Kneipe äh angesprochen, ob man mal mit dem Computer helfen kann,
oder in der, in der Sporthalle angesprochen, ob man äh sich nicht für einen CC interessiert. So, das ist schon, das sind ja schon relativ klare Zeichen und in denen in diesen Situationen ist man natürlich,
gut beraten, ähm! Also erstens auf jeden Fall ein Gedächtnisprotokoll anfertigen, ob man das nachher veröffentlicht oder nicht,
mag dann Subjekt to Discussions sein, auch wenn ich prinzipiell denke sollte man immer machen.
dann natürlich an seine Vertrauenspersonen wenden, ne? Im,
in eurem Freundeskreis habt ihr genug solcher Leute hoffentlich im Zweifelsfall, wenn ihr auf einer Liste für Anwerbung steht, habt ihr Vertrauenspersonen.
Und natürlich im in dem Bekanntenkreis eben die Warnung aussprechen und sagen hier, hör mal, da rennt einer rum, ja? Ich mein für,
Ich habe das ja äh
kommentiert öffentlich, hab das ein bisschen flapsig kommentiert und hab da unsere Quellen beim niederländischen Geheimdienst verbrannt und hab gesagt wir waren vorgewarnt ähm
der entscheidende Punkt ist natürlich, dass ist eine relevante Information, nicht nur für den CC, nicht nur für ähm ein paar äh niederländische
Tor äh Exit-Betreiber, sondern für eine gesamte Szene. Dass da äh ich meine, ist jetzt auch nicht was Neues,
Aber es ist eben klar, okay, die versuchen anzuwerben.
Also natürlich ist das äh so, dass äh Gruppen,
die sich in irgendeiner Form in der Nähe von politischer Wirkungsfähigkeit äh bewegen äh das Interesse der Inlandsgeheimdienste auf sich ziehen. Ja und von Hausen.
Da sowieso, aber jetzt bleiben wir mal bei den Inlandsgeheimdiensten und also ähm.
Es ist Aufgabe des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz sich äh politische Umtriebe in Deutschland anzuschauen,
und die unter Beobachtung zu halten. Ich weiß nicht, was die Aufgabe vom AEVD jetzt nicht unbedingt nicht unbedingt die ähm,
Aber ne, es ist klar, dass die so deren deren Aufgabenbeschreibung ist,
die Verfassung angreift, schaut, was es für politische äh Gruppierungen gibt, welche Bestrebungen die hegen,
haltet die im Blick, machen sie ja mit der Linkspartei seit Jahren im Rahmen ihrer Aufgabe,
Es gibt auch immer wieder Forderungen, das mit der AfD zu machen, jetzt gibt's aber historisch irgendwie so ein bisschen in in Deutschland die Tendenz, dass die Geheimdienste eben eher nach links gucken, als nach rechts,
weil sie in einer längeren Tradition stehen, eher nach links zu gucken, eins nach rechts, denn die haben ja mit den Kommunisten angefangen zu üben. Ähm.
Das ist bedauerlich. Ähm nichtsdestotrotz äh denke ich, dass sie ihre Aufgabenbeschreibung nachkommen,
diese Gruppen zu beobachten. So, jetzt ist natürlich 'ne andere Sache, ob die sich V-Leute in diesen Gruppierungen anwerben. So im Chaos-Computerclub hätte ich das sehr gerne nicht, dass Sie das tun,
Ähm und fühle mich äh davon bedroht, dass das passiert. Ähm aber genau aus diesem Grunde entwickeln wir ja äh eben Abwehrmechan.
Ja ich also ich weiß nicht, weil ich dazu jetzt sage.
Das wissen wir glaube ich selber besser,
Äh ich ja. Nee. Also politische Gruppierungen stehen äh in jedem,
Land der Welt wahrscheinlich unter äh unter einer Beobachtung und ähm,
Das ist erstmal, das ist erstmal der Aspekt der äh also Beobachtung, ja? Also,
wir wissen ja, wie sowas läuft, dann werden halt Medienberichte gesammelt oder sowas, ne? Äh der nächste Schritt ist natürlich dann, okay, äh hören wir die ab,
haben wir die als Marker überwachen wir die, ne? Also das ist der, das ist der nächste Schritt so eine keine Ahnung CCC ähm richtet ein Kongress aus. Ich bin mir, ich wäre beleidigt,
wenn da nicht der ein oder andere Besucher rumläuft, der nachher einen Bericht schreibt. So, dann werde ich beleidigt, wäre ich persönlich beleidig,
Das äh das findet statt und das fällt für mich unter Beobachtung und ist im Rahmen der Aufgabenbeschreibung. So, nächster Schritt ist ähm,
Infiltration oder eben Überwachung. Da hört der Spaß natürlich auf,
und da hast du aber trotzdem nur die Möglichkeit, dich eben dagegen eben Abwehrmechanismen zu haben.
Das ist natürlich die der beste Abwehrmechanismus, ähm ein weiterer ist, dass du ähm dich nicht infiltrieren lässt, dass du eben natürlich ein Vertrauensnetz auch innerhalb der Organisation hast,
das nicht so leicht zu zu penetrieren ist,
Wir haben wir haben das hast du nicht nur um Geheimdienste abzuwehren. Das hast du auch um Lohnetix,
bei der Piratenpartei gesehen, was passiert, wenn du das nicht hast,
äh also die brauchten wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal vor Geheimdienst unterwandert zu werden äh und in äh äh und äh kaputt gemacht zu werden, weil jetzt haben die schon selber hinge.
Stimmt, habe ich, habe ich auch, habe ich auch letztens äh erfahrt. In einigen Landteilen, in einigen Landtagen gibt es äh Verbleibende, Überlebende, die da äh solide Arbeit leisten,
bundespolitisch eben. Hab ich kürzlich kennengelernt, ja. Patrick, Schiffer oder Fischer heißt er,
Schiffer. Ähm nee, genau, den, den gibt's, war klar, dass der natürlich mit einem nautischen Namen oh, jetzt hast du da waren auch Wasser unterm Kiel,
So, nee, aber äh man muss seine äh Gruppierungen natürlich gegen äh gegen solche äh Infiltrationen schützen. Äh weil da natürlich irgendwann diese Beobachtung,
übergeht in aktives Eingreifen und zersetzen,
und am Ende scheitert daran dein Verbotsverfahren deiner.
Die werden dich also am Ende das ist natürlich der der Höchstjagd natürlich. Also das ist natürlich deren,
ultimatives Ziel, ne? Das ist vielleicht kommt noch die Analyse, okay, aber ja, also vorher, ja genau, also beobachten, infritieren, dann quasi überwachen und ähm bestenfalls natürlich zersetzen. Also, ich meine, du bist äh als, also,
Wenn man jetzt mal ähm so eine äh so ein geheim so ein Inlandsgeheimdienst vom Konzept her als als äh so eine Art Antikörper der Demokratie wahrnehmen möchte.
Ich glaube äh meinst du ernst das? Ich glaube, dass die sich aber als die absoluten Wächter der Verfassung wahrnehmen. Erinnere dich mal an den Landesverfassungsschützer, der bei den Datenspuren. Also es gibt ja welche, die sich auch der öffentlichen Diskussion stellen.
Also die sehen sich ja selber als Verteidiger. Also die würden ja nicht dein Bild unterschreiben,
Wieso? Nein, diese, die sehen sich doch als Verteidiger der der Verfassung und der Demokratie. Ja, natürlich. Und ihre Mittel sind erst beobachten. Äh,
überwachen, infiltrieren, um noch mehr Informationen zu bekommen und natürlich das würden sie jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht in ihrer Aufgabenbeschreibung haben äh,
aber ich mein das ist am Ende die eleganteste Methode. Äh wenn du stell dir mal vor, du würdest ein Verbotsverfahren anstrengen und dann scheitert das daran
dass du das in dem Laden so viele V-Leute drin sind
dass du nicht mehr glaubhaft behaupten kannst, dass du wie beim NSU oder bei der NDR bei der NPD war das ja der Fall vor wie lange wie viele Jahre seid ihr jetzt her.
Neue sein. Das ist das erste ImpD-Verbotsverfahren. Also zur Erinnerung. Das erste NPD-Verbotsverfahren ist daran gescheitert, äh dass die äh die,
Die Verfassungsfeindlichkeit der NPD,
zweifellos äh unter Beweis stellen konnten, weil sie nicht sicherstellen konnten, dass wenn sie alle ihre V-Leute rausholen, der Laden überhaupt noch läuf.
Ja, ja. So und dann haben dann haben die äh dann haben die gesagt, okay, dann zieht eure Frau Leute daraus und zeigt uns das und haben mit anderen Worten, die haben am Ende eine verfassungsfeindliche Partei äh selber unterhalten.
Da kommt dann eben dieses äh dieser ärgerliche Umstand, dass sie auf dem äh rechten Auge irgendwie so eine leichte, leichten grauen Start zu haben scheinen und hat eben äh jahrelang,
gut geht oder die dann eben auch in in diese offenbar 'ne sehr komischen Abwägung kommen zu sagen OK lass uns mal lieber am Leben halten,
Wir haben äh wir haben die so schön infiltriert, äh dass da natürlich dann also dann, ne, ich wollte jetzt mal so auf eine auf einer äh eher äh analytischen Ebene bleiben wie Ilandsgeheimdienste funktionieren.
A Speziele, Opfer. Ja.
Wenn ihr Gründe habt, die euch davon abhalten, dass diesen großen Schritt zu tun, an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen, dann sorgt wenigstens dafür, dass ihr in eurem Umkreis äh für die entsprechenden Warnungen,
für die entsprechenden Warnungen sorgt.
Wenn ihr äh im Chaos Computerclub seid, werdet ihr da ohnehin wissen, an welche Leute ihr euch in einem solchen Fall vertrauensvoll wenden.
Soll ich mich jetzt hinsetzen und traurig sein,
Es es gibt doch auch einen Grund zu feiern, das ist ein Anwerbeversuch gab. Der katastrophal gescheitert ist. Ja,
Ja, also so so richtig so boom, so das ist doch schön, ne? Da freue ich mich doch drüber. Ja. Bin ich, also ich fand das tatsächlich schön. Darüber bericht.
Mehr davon.
Ja, das ist also das ist natürlich der, also diese diese ganze Sache hat natürlich eine Kehrseite und das sind irgendwelche Leute, die jeden äh die am laufenden Band denken, sie würden verfolgt werden. Die ihre Chefs sind im Ohr scann
und ne und also dieses Misstrauen, dieses Misstrauen muss natürlich in einem gesunden Rahmen bleiben, man mach,
Also eine eine Form der Zersitzung äh wäre natürlich auch einfach äh die Gruppe so weit in Unsicherheit zu wegen, dass sie einander nicht mehr traut,
wie wir bei psychologischen äh da sind wir wieder, da haben wir den Bogen zu Trump, oder? Also,
Okay. Lang genug. Bedeut.
Ne, übers Haushalts reden. Genau.
Ja. Ich will da auch nicht mehr drüber reden. Ich sage jetzt die die Presseanfragen auch äh oft offiziell ab mit, ich kann nicht mehr.
Also, nächstes Mal, wenn Tim wieder da ist.
Kann sich jetzt äh inzwischen gibt's sogar übern Bundesaufbundestag, gibt's viereinhalb Stunden oder fünf Stunden Anhörungsmaterial zu zu Social Work.
Der ist noch nicht, also das ist ja nur der die Vorort. Zusammen wird's nochmal irgendwie eine Riesen. Also wer sich für Social Boards interessiert, gibt genug bei uns.
Ja, da hat er hier die Vertraulichkeit verletzt. Ja, ich meine, es war und also wir haben uns verabschiedet, habe ich gesagt, du so gerne wieder, war ja ganz nett, ne? Vielleicht habt ihr ja irgendwann mal auch mal ein relevantes Thema. Und das hat er dann auch getwittert. Dabei war das nicht voll offener Kamera, es war eigentlich unter uns.
Das ist geheim. Ach so. Aber es wird wieder eine Sendung mit Tim geben. Ich bin.
Konstanze hat mich schon längst angeworben für einen Chaos-Computerclub.
Nein, du warst auf jeden Fall äh freundlich zu mir. Finde ich schon.
Nee, nee, ist okay, ist gut.
Das Ding ist ja oft, wir haben ja hier gut Kacken, ich meine mit so einer mit einer öffentlichen Position wirst du auch nicht mehr angeworben,
also Öffentlichkeit ist äh dass äh das Schutzschild warum, also ich meine warum die deswegen heißen wir auch Geheimdienste. Na ja,
Alles klar, damit danken wir an dieser Stelle.
Du kannst dich, wenn du Tim les mal siehst zum Discodianischen. Päpstchen äh weinen lassen.
Nee, das ist ja viel zu lang für Tim. Der ist im Urlaub, der hört sich jetzt nicht zwei Stunden Podcast an.
Ich habe mich gefreut, dass du da bist und äh wir reden,
Damit bedanken wir uns bei bei allen, die sich bis zum Ende angehört haben. Ja. Und äh da auf meiner Dankesliste noch ein Fragezeichen ist, äh, mache ich den Dank äh bei der nächsten Sendung mit Tim,
ciao ciao.